there's no time o clock Hey
as you can see ladies and gentlemen we
have an action star racing 13 o'clock
that's right
I had I got address Steven Seagal such a
badass
then I got a dress up like a terminator
just to talk you know about that did
where is it a Taurus in this matrix of
bad Chuck chucks he's sleepy he kind of
snapped me so that I had to call up the
Terminator with my 13 o'clock shirt on
but my thermite my Terminator outfit the
only thing there was I don't have the
gray Terminator shirt on and I got
eyebrows oh yeah right yeah terminator
shaved off well I could solve that issue
for everybody quickly know if I ever had
to do this [ __ ] full-on I would shave my
[ __ ] eyebrows off well yeah hell yeah
I would I shaved my umbrella yeah shame
on you no [ __ ] got a pandemic going on
just stay in the house for a couple days
they come right back yeah SEP 4 all you
can say we're gonna talk about a [ __ ]
living legend man that I had a [ __ ] I
made a huge amount of respect for all
right not when they're present so we're
gonna work something out here this ago
and I want to want to start this show
off by saying that getting certain
things straight is that this is not a
Steven Seagal hate fest okay now I
understand women have a certain reaction
okay in the presence of Seagal and
talking about Segal because his you know
there are some things in his history
because if it's shittiness that's how
they do Steve let me tell you something
I don't know you might be out there I'm
a man I understand okay I have a certain
amount of understanding
of the [ __ ] that you have to put up
with you know you're a hot a huge
Hollywood star you got were you laughing
it wait wait laughing of course is a
huge Hollywood star huge Hollywood star
is super [ __ ] popular all these women
are just [ __ ] after you bad [ __ ]
huh you go to Russia you come back where
the harem it's it you know I mean I
understand you know all the haters out
there are soiling your name yeah and his
pants goodbye
okay so just that aside today this is
gonna be a fun show and we're gonna talk
about to go well there's just so much
entertaining to talk about we're gonna
try to we're gonna try to get to keep it
fair well I'm there but I'm not going
off on like I keep it fair I'm gonna
stay reading in reality okay yeah
everyone said about him
well here's the thing you know people
might want to talk about make fun of
Segal about his weight or whatever and
his [ __ ] movies and you know the
situation with [ __ ] women you know
the accusations from women in the past
and him beating up people that he was
working with on movies you know I mean
that a lot of this [ __ ] is opinion you
know I mean this is just know it is that
okay well okay all that shit's out there
but you have to imagine a time and when
action movies and everything where
Steven Seagal was actually he was over
he was a player in the action movie for
a little while yeah he was and he made
some good movies I liked under siege I
liked on a siege to a lot of people
didn't like it but I like to under siege
to I like to I like hard to kill that
was another good one and there was a few
other ones that I thought were pretty
good no his first one was above the law
yeah but the law remember that one above
the law above the law had all these
movies okay all the movies all of the
even his good movies had some issues
yeah okay and a lot of issues some of
the not a lot of issues but a few of the
issues were because of Seagal really you
know yeah I would agree with that
statement
yeah but I do respect Seagal
you know for what he did and what he
achieved and he bullshitted his way into
making movies it certainly did and he
was an Aikido expert and I saw him in
his prime doing Aikido on other Aikido
dudes and compared to their mother
Aikido dudes he looked he looked pretty
damn good
well part of it too is he was a lot
larger than a lot of I mean he's 64 so
brought 5 something right and you know
he was more aggressive that has a lot to
do with it yeah you really kind of break
Aikido apart Aikido is not really so
much about aggression it's it was it was
supposed to be kind of a non-aggression
type martial art if that's what you want
to call it some people might say that
Aikido is not really a martial art
really it wasn't really designed for
this defense fighting its defensive
right or for defending against somebody
coming straight at you but the sword you
know you can use it for that but I mean
according to Joe Rogan he was saying
like other than if a dude is coming like
right at you into your face which most
fighters don't do then it's kind of not
it you know he's not saying that it's
like not a martial art but it's just not
one that's not really used in yeah it's
an effective fighting technique that's
all now yeah it all kind of bullied his
way into making it look more effective
versus he did uses like a lot of moves
that are not really traditional so you
might be able to say that he was an
Aikido innovator all right well I'm sure
he would say that he would say problem
is you know I can go back you know to my
step-brother who was a [ __ ] bad-ass
in [ __ ] Taekwondo the problem is is
that when you take Aikido and start
making it a fight winning [ __ ]
martial art the only way to do that is
to take it outside the envelope of
Aikido now you have morphs another thing
which is what he did that was like my
step-brother he used to beat people's
asses and he was a he was like the best
guy in his dojo he did Taekwondo you
know he went all the champions he
championships he could do these [ __ ]
flying kicks he's [ __ ] great with
weapons like sighs and Tom
and [ __ ] jo-sticks and [ __ ] 3/4
staffs and he was really good with his
hands and his feet and he could do all
that and he would win shows yeah yeah
boring matches and stuff and he beat
dudes asses like it was [ __ ] nothing
back in the day
I keep take all four guys and beat a
ball all right but he didn't quite use
Taekwondo to do that you know what I
mean yeah
Taekwondo get made him limber and fast
and know how to punch and kick but
whenever I saw him fight he was fighting
outside sometimes you know what I mean
yeah outside what Taekwondo would have
been like he's not doing flying [ __ ]
kicks and all these weird things that
they would do during a tournament yeah I
mean it's just look like a dude beat
another dudes asses and stomping on me
kicking him in the face you knows what
it looked like yeah he was good he could
stand right in front of you within
striking distance of a hand you know I
mean and without you even been able to
really protect yourself from it kick you
in the bottom of your jaw with a tip of
his foot yeah that's how good he was
just wow snap a [ __ ] and you didn't
even see it coming
you know see that seems like it would be
a lot more effective than whatever it is
that Steven Seagal is do yeah the thing
is is that whenever I saw him fight
against guys for real he didn't he
didn't do that because it was easier
just to throw a punch yeah yeah no well
yeah you don't have to be a martial
artist Smith to know that so so it was
that Taekwondo he just was like it's
very basic just mostly the punches and
you know what I mean and I might use a
kick to finish a guy off yeah that's
what he was like you know but yeah
martial arts you know growing up in the
80s we had a lot of respect for martial
arts we weren't really sure what was
true and what wasn't true you know you
couldn't really look that [ __ ] out I had
friends in these dojos we're in high
school you know and like Mike my
step-brother could beat asses but then
ninja gym we called him ninja gym he's a
friend of mine he he would walk around
like he was a badass
he'd walk around and [ __ ] in his
ready stance and you know what I mean
and running around in his ghee and
[ __ ] Danny
[ __ ] and as soon as some [ __ ] would go
down he'd start disappearing off into
the background he didn't want to get in
a fight yeah that's the kind of dude I
see I like in Steven Seagal more to
someone like ninja gym because here's
the thing the and I think this is the
reason why a lot of people can't stand
him and a lot of people make fun of him
and stuff like that one because he's a
humorless douche but also he had a jump
into colleges know we even talked about
okay that he's like pretty is very
self-important and doesn't have a sense
of humor about himself he can't laugh at
himself he can be very very defensive
and sensitive like if you say something
about him but um protecting his
reputation the stupid thing is that he's
not like I mean we did the whole show on
[ __ ] oh right where some of the
people just like pulled every single
thing like out of their anal cavity that
it's like they didn't do any of the [ __ ]
that they said that they did the thing
about Steven Seagal is from everything
that I could determine he does actually
seem to be like a seventh dan or
whatever black belt in Aikido he did do
some of the [ __ ] that he said that he
did like he did like teach at a dojo in
Japan you know he can probably speak
Japanese I think although he's but it's
like he and he's been in he was in very
successful action movies in the 90s
um you know like I said he did he was
like a stunt coordinator unlike some
other movies like what James Bond movie
and stuff like that so it's like why
can't that just be enough why do you
also have to say oh we used to be a Navy
SEAL
oh I trained with the you know the
founder of aikido even though guy was
dead when he was still a teenager it's
like why like you know oh I speak four
languages when it seems that he only
speaks to maybe you know what I mean
it's like it wanted a quarter maybe one
and a quarter because like so why does
he have to like just exaggerate like you
had enough you did more than most people
do in their in a whole entire lifetime
it's like so why do you just have to
like keep adding these more ridiculous
things on top of it when clearly you are
making it up and then not even have like
a [ __ ] sense of humor about it when
people call you out on it and just want
to like punch him in the face
well he's trying to push his career
forward and to do
she has to compete with this you know
with his peers
I guess the top Chuck Norris but they
all guess see them know that's what's so
funny about it it's like everybody's
like Sylvester Stallone is dissed him
John John Clum a damaged system it's
like the cool guy other like the MMA
fighters have dissed him because he's
like oh I trained that guy that you know
I taught that guy that kick that like
knocked out the gun that UFC fight or
whatever yeah and that guy's lives that
Brazilian guy he's like yeah he's like
that guy was here and he's like and I
did kind of spar with him and stuff but
he's like he didn't teach me that kick
because there's videos of that guy doing
that kick before he even met Steven
Seagal so what the [ __ ]
okay once you start i'ma start the show
what we did already
that's how is it formally started yeah
okay but I did want to do like a couple
of shout outs before we get like really
in it this is like not um I don't really
have any kind of like structure or
anything like that I just have like all
these kind of anecdotes like other very
things I've been reading about Steven
Seagal watching like all these other
videos about him like for two or three
days so there's all kind of like fun
[ __ ] about him so like I said it's not
really any structure it's kind of like
the [ __ ] Oh show we're gonna go off
on tangents in [ __ ] so it's gonna be a
fun show yeah it should be drunker we
get the funnier it will be maybe
hopefully but I did have a couple shout
outs that I wanted to give because we
have a new patient I think I mentioned
this on one of these side track shows
whose name is Erik so hey welcome also
he comments on like a lot of our YouTube
videos and Facebook posts and stuff like
that and he also bought one of my games
oh yeah drop you know one of the GL
against I don't like I said I don't know
how long it'll take for you to get it
because I know they're there warehouse
is shut down until are there they're you
know manufacturing thing is shut down
until East 24th so it might be a while
before you get it but I hope you enjoy
it when you do get it like I said I'm
still working on other games by the end
of the year I hope to have like a site
set up that has like all the games out
there because I have like a [ __ ] ton
done I just haven't like uploaded them
yet also want to thank Melanie first
sending us another PayPal donation today
so that was very awesome so thank you
very much for that also thank you very
much to friend of the show
Sophie yeah send me two shirts that said
Tom two t-shirts today better
yeah 101st airborne shirt another one
that said I joined the infantry still I
guess so I could talk [ __ ] for the rest
of my life or something like that
she's got your number yeah she knows it
sit through the cool ones are cool
shirts they are very cool American white
American flags on the sleeves and you
know cross rifles and stuff you know
pretty cool hold on come on the back you
should wear it on the next sidetrack
show them our lead it show them off yeah
you can even change them out in the
middle like and you I can make like a
stripper sound and see that she's trying
to strip your music to try and get me in
trouble say well yeah I would just have
all these damn friend requests from all
these women you have to put in case I
get a lot of friend requests from gay
guys I'm sure they appreciate yeah just
like any other dude you know mophir
guess frisk yeah yeah yeah well I know
it's like you're your boss your raw
sexuality we'll just kind of like they
gonna resist eyes right that's what I
mean this is like so apropos that you're
doing this like on the Steven Seagal
like man man man yeah yeah well because
like I said if Steven Seagal leather
daddy man Steven Seagal is like you yeah
but without a sense of humor do you say
not right like you know baked though I
did my [ __ ] well yeah that's what I mean
but it's like you have a sense of humor
about [ __ ] yeah he does not no not at
all no and every fighter has got his ass
beat a bunch of times he loses a lot
even specially but he can do that in any
movie yeah he has like [ __ ] magic
powers jib like he can't ever I think
the only time and the only time he's
ever played a villain was in that Robert
Rodriguez movie much ethic yeah he was
in that and he actually played a villain
and I was surprised and I was like oh
maybe he does have like a tiny modicum
of self-awareness enough to play a
villain
it does seem like usually I mean because
I know some action stars like Arnold
Schwarzenegger he doesn't like to play
villains and stuff like that I know some
action stars don't like to you and
that's a business decision like because
if you get stuck playing villains you
get typecast and I understand that but
it really does seem like Steven Seagal
like even like all your action heroes I
mean the whole point of like an action
movie if your dude is like a superhero
with no weaknesses who can do everything
perfectly then there's no drama there's
no conflict there's no anything so it
seems like a good action movie would
have your hero it's like a predator
Arnold Schwarzenegger is a big giant
dude he's very powerful and stuff like
that but he's pitted against some like
an alien creature a bigger badass from
another that is a that is a bigger
badass than him so it's like it's much
more compelling but watch because he
might not I was gonna say some real
badass real badasses are fighting other
badasses right which means that they
lose a lot no you know what I mean if
you're going around fighting little
what's-his-name little uh the little
actor from John Leguizamo yeah yeah
which he was great in in and Romeo and
Juliet I love that guy he was he wasn't
land of the dead - he's been a [ __ ] yeah
corner few guys like that and it's like
okay it's almost cool this [ __ ] he's
like it's cool he's just the cool little
dude you know I love a real talented you
know great he's good actor and you know
yeah that was a story and like I saw him
tell the story yeah he was on they work
and I was executive decision right then
that has Kurt Russell in it now some
people like that movie cuz actually cuz
Steven Seagal [ __ ] dies in it spoiler
alert but um yeah so John Leguizamo was
in that and apparently according to him
Seagal comes out was he like a producer
on that movie or was he financing or
some [ __ ] like that or something like
Donnie in charge of it I don't think
he's directing yeah so yeah he didn't
direct it but so he comes out and he
says something like in total seriousness
like I'm in charge and it's like in my
way my way is law anybody have a problem
with that or something like that John's
mo understandably like laughed because
probably he thought he was like joking
like okay whatever man yes and then
poor little sensitive Steven Seagal like
it's all upset about it just punch this
guy he's like half his [ __ ] yeah
watching me he banged into mandible wall
and knocked the wind out of me I put him
in like a little hole he's good why why
did you do that [ __ ] you know they just
[ __ ] I got sensitive it was I I
laughed because like on the interview I
don't remember who the interview was
with but John Leguizamo was talking
about he's like and he's like when
Steven Seagal said that he's like I
laughed cuz he sounded like a reach
[ __ ] yeah yeah because if somebody
could seriously if somebody if Steven
Seagal came into something your
workplace that you were working on even
if he had funded it and [ __ ] and he said
came in in total total seriesis and that
stupid [ __ ] voice that he has and
he's just like my ways de Lawd he likes
it it's up I mean you would love to you
so I told you doesn't have a stupid
voice he's a fine actor okay because
he's different and I really his version
of action of acting is to put on a voice
yeah that's pretty much and that's how
he changes his race sometimes he's black
sometimes he's Italian sometimes he's
Chinese you know he can be I've never
heard him be an Irishman but that's oh
I'm sure it's out that he's made Lee a
50-million yeah he's like in the last 20
years he come like from New York he just
puts on a voice yeah his his I think his
default voice though is what's his name
Clint Eastwood he's kind of doing it
yeah yeah he's like mumbling yeah yeah
all the time he's good for it I can
barely hear ya but across all does a
Clint Eastwood voice yeah because he
doesn't go well it's [ __ ] off yeah
and he does he does John Wayne when he
was [ __ ] and uh you know big trouble
little chat he was doing John Wayne yeah
but yeah i think i think that's
Segal's standard default voice as Clint
Eastwood sounds like I said seriously I
have seen like I haven't seen like a lot
of his movies I've seen like all the you
know big action ones you know I've seen
under siege I've seen like hard to kill
all those and we watched a couple new
well we scrolled through them because I
notice that they're on but like we
thought some of the newer ones he's not
really in the new movies I thought yeah
an appearance and I saw like some clips
of his reality show which he has if you
guys said no and in that one which he
would presume he was using his real
voice cuz it's supposed to be a reality
show and it's Missy's that's not his
real boys either he's like talking like
he like he's in Louisiana right and it's
like he goes around to like you know the
neighborhoods in there call him like
answer in a college skits like cops yeah
and he goes around and he talks like no
black guy he's black it becomes black
where they at where they at yeah yeah he
uses Ebonics and it's like you don't
talk like a Ebonics stop it yeah now
what's the deal with that show because
I've never really seen that show he's a
deputy it's not a real deputy or is he
just pretending to be a deputy here's
the thing okay now this is another thing
where we're not really a cop no I don't
I don't think so well because this is
another thing where it's like there's
like a tiny little kernel a little
Orville Redenbacher popcorn kernel of
truth and then it just has this whole
big like big Jiffy Pop of [ __ ]
around it you know what I'm saying yeah
it's a reality show yeah I mean okay so
it was called Steven Seagal aw man it
ran for several seasons three seasons
earth yeah something like that it was on
some like weird channel that I don't I'd
never heard of but um no maybe it was on
A&E but then it went to a weird channel
I was never heard of because there were
two of them he did one called true
justice 2 which was fictional series but
I think he was playing a cop on that as
well okay this one is basically like
cops it said in this little bitty town
in Louisiana now from what Segal says he
was like for 20 years or whatever it was
and this was he was talking about that
this in like the late 90s or early 2000s
or whatever it was
he says for 20 years he's worked as a
cop in this parish in Louisiana he got I
guess like during one of his when he was
filming one of his movies down there
like I guess the sheriff at the time was
like a big fan so he said hey
he asked him to like come train the cops
I don't know what Steven Seagal can
teach them how to do but it's like it's
it's funny because probably hand-to-hand
yeah it's [ __ ] like that right so they
asked me to come down there so so he's
been like coming there I mean everybody
that's there says well he's not here all
the time obviously because he's not
really really a cop it's just like it's
pretty much just a ceremonial position
he kind of said I think so he's a
volunteer sheriff it pretty much because
I think he said that he had gone to like
the police academy and all that [ __ ] but
like the you know the whatever thing
that like certifies cops does not have
any record of yet made of history so
that's what I mean so that's a thing
where he is an honorary cop they're like
he does actually apparently have the
right to like go around a do cop [ __ ]
but he said oh no I've been to the
Academy and I've done this in that which
is apparently not true okay
so it's like I don't know why he can't
just be happy with his accomplishments
which are like I said he has like more
accomplishments than most people right
that are impressive so it's like why
does he just constantly feel the need to
like embellish and I know it it's just
not enough yeah he must be like a deeply
deeply insecure person because that's
something that like really insecure
people do well I think what happened is
his peers were [ __ ] with him so yeah
that's the top he's trying to constantly
rise to the occasion where my whole
contact with the Seagal started I was in
Egypt at the time on the MFO mission
with the hundred first yeah and we went
back to South Camp after I was on place
called Hopi 311 which was a was a desert
island in the middle of the Gulf of
Aqaba and they were only like six guys
on it we would pull like 25 days where
the duty on there at a time and then go
back to south camp for a few days to
rest up and then go back out there to
that island and then another phase that
was doing desert patrols but anyway well
I was back at South Campus on the vco
VHS on television with a big old big
television there at the on post or the
in camp little boy
and it was under siege yeah and
everybody [ __ ] enjoyed it we're like
oh yeah that's kind of a fun movie
I mean Steven Seagal is like he's in it
and he's like the star but he has like
other big stars it's like an actual yeah
Tommy Lee Jones is in it and uh not like
some of his other ones Tommy Lee Jones
was in it and Gary Busey Gary Busey was
in it they put on a real good show well
one of the guys next me was like yeah
man if Stephens to go he used to be a
Navy SEAL so it kind of went around he's
to be a Navy SEAL with you know we all
like everyone to know that yeah to think
that well there was some in that movie I
remember what it was later on I'm
watching it and he did something and I
was going like that that doesn't look
like oh I don't know was it how he runs
no I think I saw him how he ran later
all right cuz that's no it's something
to behold right well so this got this
evidently got the unit on a Steven
Seagal kick their outs apparently gets
the most no no they weren't trying to
get to the bottom of it it's just that
they liked that movie so they started
showing other movies okay and later on
you don't know if it was a month or so
later you know when we were resting up
again you know back to south care I saw
another movie and I think it might have
been hard to kill or something yeah
justice or that was hard to kill was 89
didn't matter what year it was yeah they
could get VHS tapes from any year yeah
but it was before was one of the older
ones and I saw his arms he was he wore
something that was sleeveless and I
don't think that was in under siege
yeah no he just had this chef's way no
yeah anyway I saw his arms and I went
whoa that dudes that that do is a Navy
SEAL I'm not like that dude is not a
Navy SEAL and then a little bit later us
and I might have been that same night I
saw him run and that was a no [ __ ]
way no [ __ ] way
because if you're in the service
especially if you're in like a combat
arms unit you've run a lot in formation
and there's a certain run a certain
cadence that just kind of gets ingrained
in you over over the [ __ ] miles and
miles and miles you know how to run
there's an efficient
we're on it yeah that dude just did not
run like a dude who had to run for his
job you know and his arms just look
there was just no conditioning in those
arms a Navy SEAL is basically an Olympic
swimmer and they're built like Olympic
swimmers you don't me there at least in
my day in those days I don't know what
they're like now I don't know if they
dropped the [ __ ] standards or what a
Navy SEAL in the 90s was almost it was
what you're talk about physical
perfection you know yeah it would have
to pay just yeah these dudes are Olympic
type swimmers and I just wasn't seeing
it so that was a big swimmer is not the
first thing that comes to my mind when I
see yeah
even as hate even in a day and they're a
little bit more bulky than an Olympic
swimmer you know not you know yeah
because because they're pretty lean they
have to be yeah they're they're actually
you know Navy SEALs like a bulked up
looking swimmer yeah and because that's
what they do you know that divers you
know some living this dude not in his
age it didn't it didn't work out because
a Navy SEALs basically a lifer he's
gonna do 20 years why is he not at his
age he should have still been in the
seals right when he said that so I'm
thinking to myself I don't think I ever
really said anything to anybody else but
I had wheels turning in my head I was
going like that can't be that dude can't
be a Navy SEAL I was like little did I
know you know I started to suspect you
know but little did I know that dude was
a [ __ ] frog when it came to that kind
of [ __ ] he was like Frank Dux
I call him Dux yeah not Dux but Dux
okay that's how it should spell yeah
there's no rule out or no [ __ ] oh yeah
duck sorry but I don't let on it these
dudes are stolen valor [ __ ]
yeah I mean they like to pretend they're
secret agents from Special Forces Delta
Force CIA all that [ __ ] rolled into one
it doesn't work that way man those dudes
are [ __ ] in those units for their
whole [ __ ] lives well yeah that's a
commitment that's a commitment you just
can't go I'm gonna be Special Forces and
do 18 months and then get out and talk
in a bar it doesn't work that way no
that dude doesn't see the light of day
until he's in his late 30s you know I
mean maybe 40s it's about time he maybe
he's done 20 years by then
and what does he do he rolls out and
then becomes some kind of contractor
security contractor making $100,000 a
year one hundred fifty two hundred
thousand dollars they make more money
when they get out of Special Forces and
when they're in you know and they vanish
they go off into some [ __ ] contractor
world they're always gone you don't you
just don't see him you know so they're
not making movies ya know that's the
thing like a lot of the timeline [ __ ] it
just says I'm where I enough it doesn't
line up like I said you know it was just
the same with him saying that he he just
can't it's almost like he just can't be
happy with what he did like okay here's
an example he's like he one of the
claims that he makes I was the first non
Westerner to open a karate to era you
know a dojo in Japan which is not
entirely a lie but it's not entirely
true either because the dojo that he
taught at belonged to his father-in-law
yeah and his wife at the time he was
Japanese also taught there as well so he
did teach at a dojo there but he didn't
open it he didn't run it it wasn't a it
was his father-in-law's dojo right now
some guys might say well Jesse the body
was a seal and he made movies true when
he was older but here's another thing
Jesse the body was not an active-duty
seal that Jesse body was in a reserve
unit yeah so he was I guess you could
say he was kind of like a part-time seal
and he never saw combat and that was
during the Vietnam era yeah when it
basically they were having a hard time
getting anybody didn't do those kind of
jobs yeah you know it's just it was
Jesse the body badass yes he was he was
very much a badass and that's why the
reason why I liked predator 1 pretty
much everybody in prayer
all those guys Rex service but like I
said that is including including [ __ ]
Arnold Arnold was a German tanker yeah I
before get that Arnold was in the
service well like I said that's what
made that movie good was because you
know those boots were real dude
if those dudes were real dudes and like
they were scared of this monster then
obviously the monster was like as big or
bigger badass than they were which like
I said that causes a lot of conflict and
[ __ ] like that if you're gonna pull the
Segal and one go around telling
everybody everybody you're badass which
you know obviously you're not about us
if you have to go around telling
everybody but also it's like in his
movies he's just he won't allow like
anyone to like get anything over on him
he doesn't he never gets hit he never
gets shot he never gets hurt it's like
and everything that happens in the
movies he knows how to do perfectly he
knows how to do everything it's like he
can't just be like in a movie and just
be like like even an under siege for
Christ's sake which was actually kind of
an enjoyable movie it's like he can't
just be a cook he has to be like an
ex-navy seal and yes an expert of
marksman and he has to be this than the
other he has to be like everything he
has to know how to do everything part of
that though was the time in which those
yeah I know a lot of them are like that
they're not lovable yeah but they were
not supposed to be realistic they were
basically fantasy movies they were hero
fantasy movies that way you know I mean
some kid that's watching it or somebody
who's watching it can kind of project
themselves into the role saying yeah I'd
do that I can do that yeah of it look I
got a cookie get the back of his head
yeah she's like yeah I'm just gonna sit
like she's like this is mystery science
theater mode she's just like yeah and
they're commenting on what mommy I mean
basically your average action movie for
a long time was was something dumb kind
of like bloodsport yeah you know it was
almost kind of like a live-action video
although that was also wildly
entertaining yeah bloodsport is a
[ __ ] classic i don't like but like
what bloodsport it's just something is
just so [ __ ] dumb with jean jean
claude von braun face and [ __ ] you don't
if he does make the best in it just
punching people in the balls and she was
[ __ ] awesome I know right yeah but
it's you don't you we didn't take that
[ __ ] seriously right a modern odd an
audience especially Millennials see that
[ __ ] they make kind of misunderstand
what you know this is what these people
watched no it's not what people watch
this well it [ __ ] the crazy
[ __ ] watch that we didn't take
it seriously
that was kind of like a live-action
version of the other [ __ ] videogame
shinobi yeah which I love that game
we'll see the thing is though that as
far as I know and please correct this
I'm not like a you know expert or
anything but it's like as far as I know
Jean Claude Van Damme didn't go around
for 20-30 years after bloodsport came
out saying that [ __ ] was real that he
had really done all no that was the
scenario that was Frank Dee Frank that's
the guy that descended that was him
actually Van Damme actually was Van
Damme was actually pretty legit well
yeah he was pretty legit he he didn't
walk around talking [ __ ] and making
things up about himself he really well
he really did most of what he said he
did and really just some he was an actor
martial artists and you know he seemed
to be pretty intelligent he had drug
problem
yeah like cocaine you know anybody I
mean like I said a lot of the martial
arts fighters it's like you know yeah
you can [ __ ] on for like you know being
an action movies and stuff like that but
most of the ones like you said you know
Van Damme and stuff like that we're
actually martial artists that had you
know documented wins and fights and
things like that bill yeah and he was
actually a really really good shape if
you were to if you were to take Van
Damme and put him in his trunks and put
put him next to [ __ ] Segal in his
prime yeah no comparison no difference
and that segues very perfectly into a
into a quote that I found by Sylvester
Stallone okay this is what Sylvester
Stallone said what a slice a van Damme
was tired of Segal saying he could kick
his ass yeah and went right up to him
and offered him the chance to step
outside so he could wipe the floor with
him here or should I say wipe the
backyard with him Russ Segal made some
excuse and left of course his
destination was some ocean drive
nightclub in Miami Van Damme who was
completely berserk
tracked him down and again offered him a
fight and again Seagal pulled a Houdini
because
knew that Van Damme would probably find
him as [ __ ] the [ __ ] disco this goes
back to meet me analyzing what Seagal
was doing in his prime you know I mean
doing Aikido they got it on film yeah
you have to keep this [ __ ] [ __ ] real
when you see what he's doing he's
dressed in a like a samurai like like
like a like a gay okay yeah it's similar
pants - what samurai war yeah
with long sleeve Carnegie shirt on top
of that he's a tall guys probably maybe
six - he's six four six six four six
five he's real tall he's very tall but
that Aikido outfit because it's so broad
because the way it's cut it makes him
look [ __ ] massive yeah and when he's
standing next to somebody else he looks
[ __ ] huge and he was dominating those
guys but it was mostly pushing and [ __ ]
like that yeah it looks like pushing or
like warm people aside there wasn't like
a lot there was one time where it got
kind of real for dudes tried to pile
yeah I just I he successfully fended him
off so I would say he wasn't incompetent
he could do yes it at least in his
heyday well if you were to take him out
of that [ __ ] outfit you'd see that he
was a beanpole yeah he was [ __ ]
skinny his arms were very skinny he
didn't have a lot of mass like raw power
all right
van Damme would have [ __ ] him up Van
Damme was [ __ ] solid and when he was
in his prime that he had a lot of muscle
on him and E was fast yeah and he was
fast and powerful Van Damme gonna [ __ ]
him up I agree yeah I think so too and
evidently Sylvester Stallone also
thought so
yeah and evidently [ __ ] evidently
Seagal thought so because he [ __ ]
he's like yeah you never [ __ ] I don't
know how tall Van Damme is but yet he's
not that tall but he's that's very
conditioned muscle and he's [ __ ] very
flexible he's very fast and athletic you
know I mean that's
he's funny though man
some about European dudes I don't want
to be [ __ ] [ __ ] on European dudes
anyway you're about to I'm about back in
those days they had a funny way of
expressing male sexuality and to look
when an American man want to look sexy
he'd probably take his shirt off
[ __ ] put a gun over his shoulder like
like a Marlboro Man or something you
know it's like he's a big old [ __ ] [ __ ]
you like Chuck Norris which is so
[ __ ] yeah yeah you have any have a
[ __ ] some moonshine in each other you
know farm [ __ ] Jeep big-ass monster
sure what a big ZZ Top beer yeah you
might reach down there and [ __ ] the
movies package over to the left side
everybody knows he's a right hand
[ __ ] yeah I mean that's the way an
American dudes gonna do this [ __ ] you
know something weird about that damn
European guys from that time they want
to get in as a little bitty [ __ ]
speedo shorts and like pose with a
leopard or something and it always kind
of looked gay to me yeah but they're
trying to appeal to everybody ladies
like it I don't know man nah dudes were
liking it well no I don't think they
were liking it on the down-low
although I'm also talking [ __ ] because
you know the main [ __ ] Arnold was
European but he got it yeah ago you know
it's funny though Arnold could look very
cool and he could do really cool shits
best bestie predator one and [ __ ]
terminator he was not very sexy either
he did not exude any kind of sexuality
no he'd exude kind of power but it was
kind of cold yeah he was like a
character yeah he does not um yeah he's
not a sex symbol I don't think so no
like I'm not saying that he's not like a
good-looking dude and he's he's in shape
and stuff like in his heyday yeah but
he's not ugly it's just there's
something not I mean he was kind of
artificial there's a difference between
like physically attractive or you know
pretty or handsome or whatever and sexy
those are two different things
sometimes they overlap but sometimes
they don't he just didn't seem to be
kind of guy that we
what would actually like dominate a
scene in a club and get a whole bunch of
women's women that you know minute and
be and be like the center of attention
women but but you know who kind of did
though so that's just alone look like he
could [ __ ] slay it yeah feeling that
he could talk yeah you know he won't
like it alone always seemed more like I
mean he always seemed more appealing
because he seems more like an everyman
because he seemed like a working-class
Joe also but he was also a writer and so
he seemed like more intelligent like it
seemed like he had something going on
that is just rocky that's not the way he
is he doesn't talk like that other
people think that I'll do your youth
yeah that was just that was just that
one character that's not how I kind of
got associated with rock that's not how
he was evidently that dude was super
intelligent he yeah yeah yeah I mean
like I said he kind of gets dinged for
playing like characters that are like
you know these Mushmouth idiots but he
doesn't as a person he never struck me
by all accounts he came in to a [ __ ]
party he was the smartest guy in the
room yeah well in the thing about it you
have to admire Stallone because he kind
of came at it I mean he wrote rocky and
he basically said I want to make this
movie and I'm gonna start at it yeah and
if you don't let me start at it then I
don't want to [ __ ] deal with you
anymore they let him do it out of all
the [ __ ] classic out of all these
dudes and we're talking about from that
era I grew up with those [ __ ]
all right I don't you some of you
youngsters they're just seeing this [ __ ]
in retrospect I was there at the time so
is she still on was the overall was the
best of them all and right behind right
there with him was was Arnold they were
different ways yeah I always like
Stallone cuz like I said he was more
like Alana's oh man but you know they
would had a huge rivalry between the two
you know
Arnie's movies I liked him better but
Stallone I like Stallone Stallone is a
better actor and he's a better actor and
he was kind of more
I don't want to see a better man they
were different I just I liked stolen
better still almost loses more
down-to-earth yeah he's more versatile
he was more talented he had like a wider
range of talents he was artistic yeah
and and and Arnie wasn't artistic he was
business minded and very driven and
disciplined but he wasn't as artistic
yeah he didn't really have and like I
said I really do feel like Stallone is a
better actor um Schwarzenegger
surprisingly has gotten better in an
older age because happy math was good
yeah after math and Maggie stuff like
that where he like played something like
use like outside of his usual type his
performance in the new Terminator was
that Terminator 7 or some [ __ ] like that
yes performance was really good I didn't
like that movie but but he acted well in
it yeah I didn't really like the role I
think they bastardized to the terminator
role a little bit and I think they
weakened him but um he did a good job
yeah he's a better actor than he ever
was yeah I think he has actually gotten
better with age but you know like he
said Stallone Steam's seems more like a
real person yeah
whereas Arnold always came across that's
why he was so good in Terminator and
stuff like that because he comes across
a little bit like a robot he's a Greek
statue
which is what which is why he's not sexy
well he's an icon of a man
yeah he's assembly symbolic of a man
yeah he's not a man you know what I'm
talking about he yeah like he is like a
Greek god the way he comes across as the
way he comes across as like a Greek god
in a in a mythological tale yeah that's
the way the movies his movies are all
kind of like yes it into a mythological
tale yeah he's crazy and all that yeah
yeah so in which there's nothing wrong
with that it's just the style that's
just like how he rolls that's how he
rolled and that was the style of the
movies that they put him in now we got
to get back to so we got to get back
Scott yeah and like I said no the issue
was Segal is that he couldn't just like
leave well enough alone it's like he had
like a handful of really successful
action movies he apparently could do
some of the martial arts and [ __ ] like
that even though I should say even
though he
I was around telling everybody that you
know he can do this that and the other
thing really the only videos of him that
I have seen doing the Aikido and stuff
like that it's always like in a dojo
yeah it's not like in a competition it's
not like in an actual fight or anything
like that whereas you know people like
you know John Claude Van Damme or
somebody like that there's like footage
of them actually like fighting or like
you know in competitions Steven Seagal
not so much it's like there's video of
him like training some people there's
some videos of him like old ones like
from his dojo or whatever where he was
doing because I was that video that you
were talking about earlier where they
were doing I guess it was like at the
black belt test or whatever for like
first students or whatever and he would
have like you know four or five dudes
like attack you and then you'd have to
like use Aikido or whatever to like get
them off and it does look like that was
kind of working but that I mean in a
dojo that's kind of a controlled
situation yeah and a lot of times you
know with my experience of old-school
dojos and the guys that were in those
dojo so those weren't the baddest-ass
some [ __ ] in the town when you
look at those guys they're Khan the guys
who were attacking on on Seagal they
were kind of milk toasty that were all
smaller they were all those eras they
were all little guys and they were
little students do you know that I mean
you're not yeah about the toughest
[ __ ] they're just trying to get
their belts when they weren't like you
have balls to the wall you know talking
about the four toughest [ __ ] in
town yeah I'm with the guys that got
beat up and went to the [ __ ] dojo to
learn to defend themselves that's who it
was
yeah let's be honest ninja gym got his
ass beat that's why he was in the
[ __ ] well I feel like that happened a
lot particularly 80s like kids that were
bullied and stuff like that they wanted
which you know that's cool big rowdy kid
I mean martial arts it does teach you
discipline it's good for your you know
physical fitness it's like you know I
don't know how good it is in a fight
depends on what kind of martial art it
is but you know it's good for your
confidence and stuff but the problem is
and I think this is another thing that
Steven Seagal has a problem with is that
you know you're good at that like you're
good at kind of sparring maybe you can
like train some people to do some [ __ ]
hand-to-hand combat maybe you know maybe
he did that to a limited extent but then
it seems like he kind of takes that and
makes it so that he's like the biggest
badass ever and he can just kick
anyone's ass but then they won't like he
won't like do it like because there is a
[ __ ] all these like MMA fighters and
like stuntmen and stuff like that they
vault like all the people that have
gotten like dissed or [ __ ] on by Steven
Seagal and he'd like you know did [ __ ]
to them there's like 12 of them they're
called the Dirty Dozen and they have an
open thing I don't know if they still
have it but they have an open thing but
it like hey Steven Seagal if you want to
like put your [ __ ] money where your
mouth is yeah we're all right here like
you know so they got 12 right there well
at least 12 willian they just call it
the Dirty Dozen there might be more than
that but you know they're basically like
well hey come on we'll fight you but he
of course he won't do it because he
would get his [ __ ] ass beat
especially nowadays because he weighs
like 400 pounds well I think what
happened was I think he had a little
successful thing going on with the
Aikido mhm for a while and I don't know
if you were able to find anything how
did he actually come in contact with the
Hollywood scene do we go um well what
ended up happening okay so he actually
did train in Japan like I said he was
married to a Japanese woman for a time
her dad had a dojo and he taught at it
him in the Japanese what they had a
couple of kids neither of which won
anything to do with him by the way it
was a daughter she's a dancer I think
now she doesn't even use his last name
she's as the mom's last name and he has
a son who's also an actor and a model
and he does not speak to his father
because apparently he's not a big fan so
um because why don't know happening was
that Seagal came over to LA to he was
working as a bodyguard for Kelly LeBrock
yeah and that Mary and that yeah well
and he [ __ ] around with his Japanese
wife with her and then the Japanese wife
got her stand away she was the woman
from we're tired science and back in the
a man yeah she was like somebody's not
[ __ ] she was like the egg girl she's
from Australia I think once she was in
Australian was yesterday or British I
think she might have been Australian I
can't really but no look Kelly LeBrock
was like the egg girl for a few years
man she is a beautiful woman though she
is yeah she and I actually think she is
pretty cool I don't know what the hell
she was doing with him and I don't know
I don't think it lasted long it did not
and they had two or three kids though
did that oh yeah
so they were together for a while and um
apparently she has not said this out
right but she is implied that he beat
her up hmm that he was physically
abusive right and emotionally abusive
which does not shock me one a little bit
well he tries to use mind games on
people so he's probably mentally abusive
or mentally abusive and when that
doesn't work he might get physical or he
may you know try to put his pimp hand on
a woman it's probably he's trying to do
you wanna hear something special this is
[ __ ] special so when they were doing
I guess it was under siege to and
Catherine Hagel who became you know she
was quite famous later on for knocked up
and several of Seth Rogen comedies went
up she was only 16 in this [ __ ] movie
and there is a photograph of Steven
Seagal hugging on sixteen year old
Catherine Hagel yeah
with his hand on her tit yeah hand on
her now she has been asked about this
she was on Jimmy Kimmel and everything
like that and they asked her about this
and she said I was 16 years old and she
said um that Steven Segal said to her
like when he met her when he was talking
to her soon I have girlfriends your age
she's 16 and she and she said why is
that illegal yeah and he said they don't
seem to mind and then she was like ma
understandably and like that [ __ ]
picture that went viral and stuff like
that you could tell from her face she's
smiling she's like please help me it was
like horrifying horrifying she was 16
yeah he is such a creep that man knows
no bounds and also allegedly we should
probably wait till after the break teen
of that but allegedly he kept sex slaves
yeah oh yeah I think that that's been
mischaracterized but um I don't think I
think it was mixed carry well honestly
he has had
so many [ __ ] sexual harassment
accusations against him and like even
famously what like Jenny McCarthy and
like she's a crazy anti-vaxxer whatever
but that doesn't mean she deserves to
get [ __ ] sexually harassed so you know
she had a claim against him several
other actors you know had claims against
him Portia de Rossi said that she that
he had sexually assaulted or sexually
harassed her there's several of his
executives like his assistants like
people that work for him and stuff like
that so it's like a lot so I feel like
that many you can't really ignore that
so this is the sex slavery thing I think
he just had hookers on the payroll
that's what I think that was good no no
and I'm pretty sure was underage they
were underage a sex slave implies that
you captured a woman or bought a woman
from slaves to say McCarran allegedly I
think it's kind of a stretch I don't
know I kind of feel like as well exactly
the type of dude that would do I think
that [ __ ] got dropped but I think what
it was I think was just hookers on the
payroll I think he paid everyone off as
maybe they did because I think a lot of
the accusations that were made against
him like suddenly he like talks to the
lawyers and then suddenly the the
allegations disappear so I think like he
paid some people off like to stop
talking about it okay liked paid the
victims off or whatever hey here's like
a hundred thousand dollars or something
like that just shut up
is it time for a break um let me see
yeah probably worried about an hour in
alright so we're gonna take a break
probably refill drinks maybe well maybe
no no I think I have less but yeah so we
got it going by fast we got to think of
some more like [ __ ] there's so many
more [ __ ] stevegarson we got to come
up with some more [ __ ] there's so much
more of these like out there huh this
dude is just like a fascinating
character I'm telling you man I mean
this isn't a paranormal case you might
want to call this true crime I don't
know what you want to call this well
it's got something for everybody it's
got so for everyone to to me it's just
entertainment and I wanted to have a
good fun show tonight and I think this
is a [ __ ] fun show even though like I
said you know people are being nostalgic
along with us
you can laugh about it and [ __ ] like
that but I mean we make jokes during our
serial killer shows too even though
we're making jokes about terrible people
this is just another one of those Steven
Seagal is not a serial killer that we
know of but he's just kind of he also
kind of sucks and it's funny to make fun
of him just because he thinks he's super
awesome okay that was Steven Seagal as
long as long as he was as long as he was
[ __ ] respectful with me if you
started sucking tongue see I don't think
that's what would happen though be a
dick the second that you tried to it
like seriously everybody that has ever
worked with him like everybody does him
even like stuntmen that have worked as
movies like Kane Hodder the guy that
plays Jason Voorhees on several of the
Friday the 13th movies every single one
of them had said look he's a giant
douche it's like he comes on the set he
tells everybody else what to do he's
really really condescending and it's
like he won't like he doesn't want our
hearse he doesn't want to like when they
try to do like you know rehearse the
parts and it's like hey you know don't
like pull your punches like you're
supposed to it's a movie and it's like
he won't do that
like he'll really hit people and really
and they're just like hey Steve like
chill the [ __ ] out but it's like it just
seems like he's so insecure that he has
to go around like all the time like
swinging his dick around and it just I
don't know it's it just seems like it's
gotten it at this really horrible
feedback loop now we're like the more
people make fun of him the more dick the
more of a dick he becomes because he's
just gonna go around singing like Oh
everyone's picking on me because I'm fat
and because of my weird hair line and
because of the weird way I run and stuff
like that so it's one of the best lines
ever and seriously if you go like I used
to read them cracked calm all the time
and I don't know if you guys know but
like the best writer on there and he
only puts up stuff like every now and
then it's called Shawn baby and he wrote
one he read he read the stupid crazy
novel that Steven Seagal wrote if you
guys didn't know um and he also weren't
called seven superpowers that Steven
Seagal thinks he has but he's like he's
written all these articles about him and
one of the best lines that he ever said
about [ __ ] Steven Seagal was it he
runs like a penguin was kidding
now do you have the set do you have the
seven superpowers I think you know what
I can look it up during the break all
right it's a very long article and I
can't like I probably can't read the
whole thing because it would just be
like copyright infringement right but um
yeah so there's like a lot of really
funny [ __ ] on crack tech because they'd
never tire of like making fun of see
it's it's fun to make fun of him just
because he's so self-important and think
and he takes himself so seriously and
people that take themselves that
seriously are just like [ __ ] ripe for
mocker yeah you know thing is is that I
like Steven Seagal's
in an ironic kind of way I mean you know
I mean like a lot of people do yeah
there's anyone genuine like I'm sure
somebody knows well I've never met the
guy you know I mean I'd have the [ __ ]
meet up in person and you know maybe
he'd be maybe he'd be cool to me you
know I mean what was the dude to go the
the basketball player that went to North
Korea who said that Dennis Rabbitt
Dennis Rodman said that you know Kim
jong-un was good to him maybe that's all
that matters all that matters he can he
can he do they don't matter nice to me
no I'm all good I'm all Rodman status
yeah yeah I'm alright no just on general
I'm more judge of personal how they word
are to me yourself cut off Saturn I
can't control what they do and their
relationship with the world you know the
man I can't control it you can tell them
that they suck though well I could do
that too but I'll be you know if they're
polite to me that I'm playback
I kind of not been feeling that like
knowing your personality stings because
he would rub me the wrong way probably
yeah yeah and and he would rub you the
wrong way probably immediately I mean
like cuz he just rubs me the wrong way
just watching him he probably drove for
five seconds on YouTube I'm already like
nope but you know I'm this is just as
you would end up punching immense desert
looking theoretical meeting between me
let's imagine this how we go down and
Steven Seagal alright my in my mind the
way I see it was is that theoretically
if he was cool to me I'd be cool with
him alright I'm gonna give him that you
know like the
benefit of the doubt you know I mean
because just because that's how I am
it's a man you know but if he started
acting sideways with me yeah I'd be like
man [ __ ] you dude well see that's the
thing although it's like he would
probably immediately start acting
sideways with you because one he seems
like really really massively insecure
yeah which means that anybody that had
done something that he hadn't done or
was bigger than him or her get like bum
hurt and then he would lash out by being
a giant condescending douche he knew
which is what it seems like he acts like
that toward everybody and like I saw
some clips from his [ __ ] reality show
so he goes in there like I said he's not
a real cop he's like a ceremonial cop in
this parish or whatever
he's like an auxilary police yeah and so
he goes there to like train them which
they did at apparently the sheriff at
the time he's not the sheriff there
anymore but the sheriff at the time was
a fan of his movies and like asked him
to come and like do the training and
stuff and apparently that did really
happen so I'm not saying that he made
that up or anything but the footage they
have of him on this reality show like
teaching the cops and stuff he just
seems like the world's biggest
mansplaining douche hat and it's like
and he's just like telling these people
how to do their jobs like this handy
hang like how to shoot a gun it's like
they're cops they know how to do the
[ __ ] it's like just he's just showing up
he's just trying to make it look good
for the camera yeah and it's like just
stop it and it just seems like
everything and every actor that's ever
worked with him like the the whole cast
of Saturday Night Live like when he was
on there hosting they every single one
of them said he was the worst host they
ever had because one he was completely
humorless all he did was come in and
criticize everybody and he thought he
knew better like how to do everything
like these people that have worked there
for hundreds of years or whatever and
he's just like comes in and he wants to
do this that in the other it's like he
didn't want to do this was back in the
day when they had Dana Carvey and all
them and they did like the Hans and
Franz schedule yeah and he's like he
didn't want to do a Hans and Franz
sketch because part of the sketch was
that Hans and Franz were saying that
they would kick Steven Seagal's ass
you know no no you know it's like I said
he can't like [ __ ] joke about
anything he has no sense of humor at all
about himself particularly yeah and like
he just called them all stupid and all
this other kind of crap and he was just
like and also I heard that he wanted to
do like he wanted to write his own
sketch about a therapist who was canoe
was consulting with a rape victim and
how he wanted to have sex with her oh
yeah and I'm like what the [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] is the matter with you so like I
said this is the problem that I have
with the dude it's just like well I
thought that [ __ ] was funny he thought
it was funny but nobody else did
obviously because that's kind of not
funny but it's like but he wouldn't like
let the Hansa fronds even though that's
clearly a joke he wouldn't like let
himself be the butt of a joke yeah at
all because like I said he just can't
yeah and that's why people pick on him
just because it's so easy yeah
because he's so [ __ ] sensitive but
it's like everything like you can't he
just doesn't have any self deprecation
he doesn't have any sense of humor
anyway great yeah so let's take a break
I actually might look up that article on
Mike and see cuz I read it through a
couple times too
yeah if there's six or seven superpowers
that are concise they'd like to hear
what they are okay okay well I'll look
it up during the break and then we'll
talk about it it's the way back in just
a couple of minutes what are you doing
huh what are you doing mom huh
I'm playing you on TV look at how cute
you are look at how cute you are you
know you're cute you can't help yourself
can't help yourself I know you're not
doing anything exciting cuz it's like
your naptime
she just lays around on the bed all day
sheelane around the bed all night - she
was like sleeping up at my elbow pretty
much all night yeah wash your feet all
right
Oh leave me alone I don't bugging you oh
goodness yeah yeah you have an
exhausting life don't you go cool yep
roughly you love true crime I love true
crime and I've spent the last three
years compiling a series of the most
intriguing unsolved murders of the 20th
century it's called the faceless villain
and volume three is available now
featuring such fascinating cases as the
Caddy murders the carry baby's case the
Frog Boys the al-qasr murders and the
inokashira park dismemberment incident
the faithless villain volume three is an
involving exploration of unsolved slang
spanning the years from 1980 to 1999
pick up your copy and print or eBook
formats on Amazon or download the
audiobook version from audible.com and
get ready for a chilling journey through
modern crime history
so do you want to be cheesy and say that
now that we're back in the back you the
back from the break you can say I'll be
back I'll be back see I thought I'll be
back to do it alright so we're back
talking randomly about Steven Seagal bad
action movies in general kind of but
mostly about Steven Segal so here's one
thing that I neglected to mention when
we were talking about cuz you guys
there's so many [ __ ] stories about
this guy so um you know that reality
show where he did cop [ __ ] you know that
I was talking about earlier yeah Steven
Seagal aw man
yeah so the first season or two were in
Louisiana but then it got moved to
Maricopa County Arizona so he can work
with Sheriff Joe Arpaio
okay yeah yeah there was one episode of
the show where they were going to
investigate yes someone who was
suspected of running a cockfighting ring
which is not good but not you know a big
[ __ ] crime right so Seagal and his
little buddies decide that they're gonna
go full [ __ ] Waco on this [ __ ] they
have a tank they have like all the
[ __ ] [ __ ] so they come into this
dude's house and this dude is not like
convicted of it or anything like that
he's just suspected of cockfighting yeah
they drive a tank through the front of
his house damn they have like [ __ ]
armed offs like all over the [ __ ]
place [ __ ] like that and he's an
auxilary cop he's doing this yes okay
him and Arpaio okay it's like
information yeah yeah okay so they do
all this crap allegedly they kill this
family's puppy they shoot the puppy damn
also uh you know the guy that they were
kept he pleaded guilty later to
cockfighting but he had like a hundred
and fifteen chickens and you know how
Steven Seagal is I was kind of like Oh
animal rights and everything like that
all of those chickens were euthanized
right yeah those were the chickens
they were supposed to be saving right
yeah by doing this [ __ ] oh we're
gonna drive a tank through the [ __ ]
front of this dude's house it's like I
said I don't agree with [ __ ] fighting
but that seems a little extreme
yeah some of this animal protection [ __ ]
[ __ ] I don't buy it it's all [ __ ]
because it does get down to dem killing
the animals that they're trying to
protect well that's exactly what he did
we just got done watching the [ __ ]
tiger king you know everybody's seen the
[ __ ] tiger king yeah if that the
[ __ ] authorities had their way about
it they would say oh all this shit's
curled animals they going in to kill
every one of those [ __ ] Tigers well I
don't know about that yeah you know
immunize them cuz where they gonna put
them where are you gonna put them
we'll see you can't release them back in
the wild no but they should at least
like try to make an effort there are
like several zoos and stuff like that in
the US that would take them maybe a few
of them yeah
not all of them he had 200 of them I
mean yeah that's what I didn't write
them that's why they that's why they
weren't raiding them because they know
the guys from the system knew all [ __ ]
if we go in there and [ __ ] take all
those damn tigers mad dude we'll have to
end up killing every one of them but
that's what's funny but about this [ __ ]
see this is another thing that pisses me
off about Steven Seagal is that one he
pretends to be a Native American which
he's not he's [ __ ] his mom he knows
what race he is yeah actually it's not
his mom was Irish and his dad was a
Russian Jew yeah actually no that's not
the exact thing that he said well he
said you're gonna go by what he said
yeah this is what cuz it was much better
yeah he was um okay know what he was
Italian he was half Italian okay no half
Irish and part Jewish he's half I have
enough Jewish half-irish half-jewish no
no no that's not that's not what is half
Italian that yeah yeah yeah there was
more than one and a half one and a half
he said he were because he said that
that he's like what is that what it is
the quote that I remembered was that he
was half Irish half Italian and part
Jewish
that might be a hundred and thirty five
percent ya know it's something you 50%
hi
maybe well he didn't see how big of a
part just part Jewish he's half Jewish
his dad there's a Russian jail okay cuz
one of the quotes that I heard was is
that he was hacked half Irish half
Italian
and part Jewish that's 50/50 and then
maybe what 2595 I'm not making any
assumptions based on the fraction yeah
yeah that's pretty cool even though he's
pleased to have a half in part but he
pretends he's Asian though even though
he's not even a single part Asian he can
talk Chinese though he's all of a sudden
yeah I've seen him just at the drop of a
hat just go complete Chinese on you does
the Japanese accent or Chinese accent I
remember saying that the wiser he gets
the more Asian he becomes okay you see
that I've seen it happen I feel like the
last few years he's gone more in the
magical Native American direction is it
okay which is weird because like I said
he kind of went in this weird thing
where okay so one of the stories and I
can't prefer the name of the actor I
know like I know his face he's like a
very famous like character actor and he
was in a movie playing a serial killer
and Steven Seagal was in it as well now
apparently Midway during the making of
this movie he Steven Seagal decided that
I don't know he didn't want to kill
anybody in movies anymore because it was
bad karma I don't knows against Shinto
or whatever like he didn't worry about
that before it's like you know people's
arms off or whatever I mean against
Aikido
yeah somehow like it took like this long
for him to figure that out so so he
decided in the middle of him and he
became like really difficult about it
and apparently so this guy playing this
is like look he tried to like talk him
into he's like look it's like um you
know you're denying me my my right like
I'm a serial killer right in the movie
so he's like you're like denying me my
you know you know I that I can die and
become reborn
like learn [ __ ] and everyday so you're
denying that to me by not killing me so
really you should kind of kill me in the
movie and eventually like he did kind of
talk to him and like it seemed like
Seagal was kind of like on board with it
but then like he didn't want to do it
so this actor had to come back and he
was like I to go back and like do like
all this ADR like post-production
because apparently Seagal had been like
slipping stuff like ad-libbing in the
rest of the movie that he oh I'm so glad
I didn't kill that guy bla bla bla
he was like adding lines like that and
they couldn't get him to stop doing it
so they had to make this poor actor come
back and like reloop a bunch of his
lines that made it look like he lived
right even though at the end of the
movie it's like what it was supposed to
be was like he was supposed to shoot him
in the heart the heart like blew up and
there's like this big explosion or
everything and he's like in it so he's
like so I had to like have all these
like lines that I had to really like him
is oh I'm still alive I was like just
kill me you bastard whatever an
explanation for there's an explanation
for all this his peers kept [ __ ]
ribbing him and [ __ ] publicly making
fun of him that scene that he was all
into Aikido right but Akita was
nonviolent yeah but his movies were just
nothing and just beat the [ __ ] I did
like hypocritic so he was trying to
trying to cover his own yeah he was
trying to make it look like he was a
real martial artist and that he really
believed in what he you know in the
philosophy of Aikido and now he wanted
the movies inflect that that [ __ ] would
bomb and the [ __ ] movies alright the
directors were right don't [ __ ] put a
key that even that actor was like dude
I'm doing character is a serial guys
yeah or nobody's gonna like the movie so
he was kind of I guess you could say he
was kind of buckling under the [ __ ]
under the he was buckling under the
pressure that people were putting on him
behind hey your movies are ultraviolet
but you know but the thing well the
fairies were yeah but but they're not
going around alright yeah and
I can like enlightened they are yeah he
was going around [ __ ] going on with
this Eastern philosophy and pulling that
[ __ ] out of his ass of public so they
used that against him yeah so I was like
don't [ __ ] should have been shut he
should have shut his mouth yeah that's
what I'm saying that's what his whole
problem is a he ran his mouth is that he
just keeps running his mouth and like
the weird thing is like he has like this
really weird like he has like these
really weird like schizophrenic like
from one end it's like he seems like
extreme hippie but then he seems like
extreme right-winger at the same time
it's like this just really weird like
contradiction but it's like he's always
kind of he's making things up yeah and
it's like it seems like he hasn't really
thought [ __ ] through yeah so like I'm
saying that's that's kind of what like
annoys me about him and like I said you
know nobody is complaining that action
movies are violent or that because you
know it's like that's what action movies
are like and people like them for that
they were [ __ ] on him because he was
going around trying to make like some
big [ __ ] statement about how
nonviolent he was and like meanwhile in
the movies he's like you know punching
people through the face and [ __ ] like
that it's done there are there were
something you know I mean
Ginnie's kind of focusing a lot on the
negative alright which I can understand
that were present I am I can't stand the
dude that's like I didn't say some good
things you know on certain shows like he
did defend Russia okay so people are
really down on Russia and he's like when
you hear Americans talk about Russia
they think it's all just a bunch of
gangsters and immoral [ __ ] gangsters and
hookers and he he kind of said Russian
people are just normal people like
everybody but you know he was tired of
hearing people slandered you could see
he still lives them he lives there he
says it's a nice buddies with pooty-poo
yeah that's a weird that's a weird angle
I don't know how Putin got sucked into
this well see I don't had to have known
I don't know okay now what I heard from
one of it not from not from putti but
for some of the some of his handlers or
some of the other people high up in the
government said basically that Segal
bugged us until we like introduced them
and like made him some kind of like
[ __ ] emissary
some [ __ ] like that like he just kept
bothering them and it
they were implying that it's like he
just kept bothering us so we were just
like kind of getting him to shut up
maybe that's not what they met but
that's kind of how I read it
yeah um he has like met Putin yeah and
he's like I'm the second Putin's
organized Oh in recent years it does
seem like Putin has kind of been like
yeah just stay over there it's a good
thing all that I saw some old Putin
looked amused by him I kind of think
that Putin knew he was kind of fraud
that's maybe I feel like Stephanie Segal
is the only person that's not in on the
joke of Stephens yeah yeah and I think
pooty-poo [ __ ] looked at him and goes
this [ __ ] is a trip like in this
[ __ ] crazy [ __ ] and he has a
crazy person they had they had [ __ ] they
had they had Segal out there [ __ ]
like destroying an entire army of
Russian kids did you see that no I
didn't say that oh yeah well I saw like
a lot of [ __ ] they had all these Russian
kids and gays and he's out there doing
Aikido and up little kids I got some
kids you know the media there were our
twenties of 30s you know the main bucket
and he's tossing them this way in this
way to me I'm looking I'm going like
this [ __ ] looks fake as [ __ ] it does
look Vegas okay well every everything
that I've seen with him and be like
demonstrating this yield
it always looks fake fake this book and
then you look at my background is
basically going yeah they're going oh oh
my god and you look at the background
all the rush all the Russians and their
gaze and [ __ ] you know watching watching
the demonstration and the look on their
faces like is this [ __ ] real yeah okay
so even if you're really there it still
looks yeah seriously everything and I
you know I haven't seen every [ __ ]
video of you know of Steven Seagal in
action or whatever if you want to call
it that but it's like I have seen like
some stuff even from like his old dojo
and stuff like that for real it's like
if any of your into Aikido I'm not like
I'm not poking fun or anything like that
but it does really seem like every
single thing is like just him going oh
yeah what can a guy like falling down
you know what it looks like it looks
like no effort I'm trying to get a word
in here edgewise a key to
now you had the feeling this [ __ ] folks
it's like this all the time Akito words
against people who don't resist it or
people who know that you don't yeah that
there be there in an Ikea works against
people who don't fight back from what
I'm saying yeah as long as you're kind
of polite about it like yeah you got me
okay all right fair enough
yeah that's what it looks like to me I
don't ever seen the bay flip around one
oh [ __ ] you you know the minister
fighting and kicking you know and like I
said you have to submit to Aikido yeah
and I have watched like a couple of
videos by like some actual martial
artists yeah and they have said the same
thing they're like we're not saying it's
not a martial art we're just saying is
that an effective martial right yeah
it's not effective and they're like you
know obviously a lot of the [ __ ] that
you see like our demonstrations and
those are people that are showing you
it's a demonstration so they're showing
you the technique yeah so it's like
they're supposed to be like hey this is
how this works it's like if somebody
actually fought back with any like you
know strident kind of like you know
effort then you would be hosed when we
were kids you know back in there back in
them early to mid 80s even late 80s
there was no internet there wasn't any
way to check up on anything and if you
had friends who when you're in high
school who were in martial arts and you
we watch movies you know [ __ ] karate
kids you weren't really sure what was
real and what wasn't real with it or
what was possible but the only printed
material we can really get was like
black belt magazine and in those days
and black belt magazine was [ __ ]
crazy you weren't really sure what the
[ __ ] we talked about that some like yeah
black belt magazine would discuss chi
balls and knocking people over without
touching them and wattage punches and I
won't touch the arches no touch [ __ ]
knockouts
they're talking about the [ __ ] force
yeah you know but there were some about
it being in a magazine and then wearing
these geez it's written down in three
and everything and it goes back
thousands of years and [ __ ] its
ancient [ __ ] maybe there's some to it
you know that was the thinking of the
time of the Irish person but little did
we know and here's the little did we
know that one day MMA would come
actually Ultimate Fighting came first
weekend at the beginning of MMA and
those dudes wouldn't show up to fight
yeah well I wonder why if they yeah
creamed right and then you'd have MMA ya
know and these these [ __ ] karate
people wouldn't show up to fight and
then you just cut and then some of them
you find out they're the guys that are
mmm MMA fighters are extra rowdy at X
Taekwondo that they started off in that
and they were kind of going like now
that [ __ ] didn't work yeah and that was
what lady in early 90s something like
that yeah I remember when the whole
concept its it I mean a lot of people
have grown up today with MMA and it's
just like something they take for
granted that you know you're fighting
and you're punching you're kicking there
aren't any real rules you just fight
until somebody submits really you know
there are no boxing gloves or anything
when I was a kid we would have thought
something like that would have been
illegal the cops show up I was like the
kumite there was like yeah that's where
they came from that's what your citta
madam bloodsport that there were no
rules is just fight and people get
killed and [ __ ] people got killed in
boxing but we didn't think of it that
like that yeah oh man people would get
killed
they only do that in other countries
that did it and that's where the whole
kumite thing and bloodsport came from
yeah and it was like something that only
like the tongs would do something like
that was [ __ ] that's just MMA you could
see that on [ __ ] pay-per-view yeah
you know nowadays so it's kind of if you
were to tell me to you know as a kid hey
man in 2020 the idea of the kumite and
fighting and it's gonna be MMA and it's
just me commonplace I would have thought
you were [ __ ] crazy
yeah well some ways though I've been
like man that's like some [ __ ] out of
running man running man [ __ ] you know
with
accion matter new Mad Max been out
thought they'll never do that that's
illegal no no right well as soon as that
[ __ ] started to come into fruition you
know you slowly started seeing ideas
like the kumite and [ __ ] and [ __ ]
Taekwondo and ninjas and all that [ __ ]
thats all starts to evaporate
well yeah you slowly sound like the
bullshitty of martial arts they all
disappeared like homer and edge I mean
just like that famous gift and it's like
but that's good though but I feel like
Steven Seagal never got that memo
because he was you know he was in
[ __ ] the old school where you can
[ __ ] that's what I mean but he's
still like out there saying that he was
the CIA a properly trained CIA and he
was like [ __ ] Navy SEALs as a kind of
crap and like I said you know he's not
one of the ones that he's like he wasn't
even like a real martial artist or as
long as he was and he was in like some
successful movies but martial arts
weren't real yeah and and it was in a
martial art that is not that effective
in you know fighting or in competition
that's all I'm saying
yeah the closest like the closest thing
to MMA they had when I was a little kid
were rumors of something that evidently
existed a long time ago when I was good
the black dragon fighting Society which
that's like a countdown town don't they
from the back of the damn comic book I
mean that was a real dude they're like
the rest we are one day we are do a show
about [ __ ] counter well we talked
about him on the [ __ ] yeah we talked
about on [ __ ] he actually was for
real it was kind of like he was also
[ __ ] crazy yeah he wasn't crazy he's
[ __ ] crazy but it's like count dog
but in a kind of an awesome way yeah he
was a a pioneer really yeah when he was
doing is what Bruce Lee was talking
about yeah that's what Bruce Lee was
talking about and he was doing it so
whatever it's you know I don't know it's
just kind of like like I said the thing
that about Steven Seagal that bothers me
is that he doesn't he's not like on
board
he seems like completely not like
self-aware he's not aware of anything
you just have seven superpowers though
don't read Disney yeah
I was gonna say that like even Chuck
Norris because you know how they had the
whole thing like it feels like Chuck
Norris facts and all that of the oh [ __ ]
now I will say that Chuck Norris
initially was really a douche about that
and like tried to sue the guy that like
wrote that book but over the years I
guess since it was so successful he is
kind of like grudgingly like accepted it
so he's a little kind of a little
humorless - yeah but not to the same
extent that Seagal is Chuck's a little
weird especially as he got older yeah he
doesn't want him he's always been kind
of weird but he doesn't want anybody
cussing in his movies that's consum yeah
he's done like super super like
fundamentally yes really really that's
just really not [ __ ] mesh into well
with entertainment yeah well yeah
there's a reason why that yeah there's a
reason why Christian entertainment and
regular entertainment it's just there's
only one [ __ ] Christian movie that I
saw that I liked which one was that that
was the one about the dude who's
captured people and dragging them back
to his house and telling his kids that
they're demons that they have to kill
him oh frailty frailty so it's called
and then it turns out that they are
demons yeah it's like oh I guess you can
see that as a Christian movie but yeah
that's a good movie yeah that's a good
but it didn't really bill itself as that
that's what it was though it was yeah it
was but yeah but it was also a good
movie it was well-written it was well
acted that's how you write a Christian
movie yeah it's like don't do this weird
[ __ ] reach are like shoehorn some kind
of like [ __ ] [ __ ] in there they just
kind of presented it like a straight
horror movie without like overtly trying
if I were to make a [ __ ] critic Noah
was a Christian movie and there's an
aunt a Jewish movie that was done right
also good Darrin and I are yeah see that
movie that's a [ __ ] bit that is what
they're talking about in the Apocrypha
and [ __ ] you know said like well
that's what I mean it's like it's really
cool that he made a movie I mean he's
verbatim as far as I know he's an
atheist but like but I just thought it
was cool that he made he's like well
this is exactly what it says so I'm just
gonna react to the source material and
people some people some Christians don't
realize that there are extra cannon
uncle texts about Genesis that are not
in the book of Genesis the apocryphal
type and a lot of that is in there too
and if some of that stuff came from
Jubilees I think yeah which they're not
in the Oh the Christian version of the
Old Testament they had some other stuff
that was extra canonical you know but
still from that same time but it was
respectful to the source material and
that it was like something out of Lord
of the Rings yeah I would love to make a
Christian movie my Chrisman be called
revelations dcg to actually just tell
the [ __ ] location and it would be
right out of the [ __ ] book just
exactly exactly exam with CG and [ __ ]
yeah crazy craziest [ __ ] ever and I
would like to say drop acid before I
would have [ __ ] old texts and tomes
going across and yeah and be semi
narrated and it was showing us stuff
yeah I'd watch that you got buck blowing
I know cuz CG you could do that now
well yeah you can do all I have wormwood
[ __ ] splashing down and [ __ ] them
the one third of the fish dying and one
third of the boats doing this and that
and I'd have him [ __ ] out of having
making the beasts talk and move and have
all that yeah yeah okay I would just
have my own spin on it but it would be
stylish it would look like you know
something Roman you know that would work
I'm surprised look like first century
Rome instead it just seems like now it's
like every now and then we'd see like
trailers for like some of the Christian
movies and stuff like that and they just
don't look so like formulaic and cheesy
and Kirk Cameron's probably in it and
it's kind of like man I don't want to
watch that [ __ ] it's like and if you
guys don't know there is a [ __ ]
podcast called god-awful movies and it's
not really easily offended I will tell
you that right now but it's three guys
and they basically it comes out every
week and they review Christian movies
you know Christian movies and they're
long it's like they'll sit there and
like go through the whole [ __ ] movie
and like talk about every scene and so
it is fun is funny it's holy
Oh a night they're not known for making
good movies yeah it's it's sad I have
this really funny book called rapture
ready where this guy is like a
journalist or something like that and he
kind of went in like he went into like
the Christian I guess you would call it
the Christian ghetto or whatever where
they have because they have their own
like entertainments not just movies but
it's like in here in Orlando we have
that theme park what the [ __ ] that
called holy land
yeah it's Jeezy and yeah and he's like
so he went there and it's like so he was
talking about like all their TV shows
and their music and stuff like that and
how how weird it was like it was like
this weird separate like subculture and
like why that was and stuff it's a funny
book too but it's like it's also kind of
like know what else is a Christian movie
um The Exorcist when you think about it
that that's great yeah you could call it
that that's probably the greatest
Christian movie evolved and I think a
lot of Catholics were into it at the gym
because they're like yeah man the devil
so you can't it is possible it's
possible to make a badass obviously
Ashton because the Exorcist one of the
best movies ever yeah and uh you know
and I like Last Temptation of Christ and
Christians at the time or protest in the
movie but I liked it I liked it cuz
there are certain things that were not
like it but anyway we gotta get back to
this to go to say about the goals - is
that it who was it that I think Rob
Schneider told this story but he was
talking about he said he heard it from a
friend of his who was a writer and he's
like this writer was either working on
under siege - or like are supposed like
under siege 3 which I guess never came
out he's like so he's on the set and he
goes in to talk to Segal and he's like
Seagal hat is in this like big like a
mobile home but he's like he had one of
this big like super fancy ones like with
all the pop outs and [ __ ] so he goes in
there to talk to him but he's like so
Segal comes out and he's like kind of
like wiping a tear from his eye or some
[ __ ] like that and he's like I just read
the best screenplay like ever written or
something like that and the writers like
really who wrote it like completely like
not ironically like he was not trying to
be funny or anything like that yeah and
that's what I'm saying he's just like
completely clueless and this is why
and I've read like some [ __ ] people that
like did makeup on like some of the
cheap-ass movies that he did because
he's done like a zillion movies like
what if like I think in 2016 he made
like seven [ __ ] movies yeah but like
you said he's only in him for like five
minutes yeah he's only do sir really yes
so it's not really that big a deal but
I've heard from some people that like
worked on some of the movies that he
shot in like Romania and [ __ ] like that
and they're just like he is just the
most insufferable person to be around
because he's just difficult it's like he
thinks he knows everything it's like he
has no sense of humor no he just like
thinks everyone has beneath him for some
reason and he thinks he's just better
and he knows better and he just goes
right it's like he says [ __ ] like and
this is going back several years but he
says [ __ ] like oh he wants to be known
for like doing cool [ __ ] and like not
just as a sex symbol I'm like I didn't
know that he's six even back in the day
was he really a sex symbol yeah maybe
for a year or two I'll tell you what we
saw one is from 2016 it was on you it
was on Netflix it was called sniper
sniper special ops and everybody else
was doing all the acting and he's he's
doing he's got about 10 15 minutes and
in the movie yeah it's that yeah it
actually didn't look that bad a lot of
people really were doing a good job in
the movie he's just that the scope of
the movie was really small they could
only shoot yeah he went tell it was
low-budget yeah they can only shoot it
in that one little location and I would
say Seagal made the movie happen without
his money it never would happen but
Seagal was actually kind of the word I'd
hate to say this Steve you you were
actually kind of the worst thing in the
movie but you had to be in the movie or
they wouldn't have bought the movie and
put it up in there so I understand what
the deal is
he basically all he does in the movies
is dog sits sits occasionally snipe
somebody and Bumble yeah and mumbles a
little bit
anytime here's the deal I knew I knew
its [ __ ] it's [ __ ] time for Stegall
to hang it up when he needed a stunt
double to walk down the stairs for the
sign track show but I'll say to get into
people that aren't watching those I was
making a joke
there was a scene of like him supposedly
walking down the sit let's just walking
downstairs not running not like [ __ ]
doing anything I recover I just walking
down the stairs like a normal person and
I made a joke
cuz you know MST so I'm used to doing
that so it's just kind of like oh yeah
the stunt double to do that but then I
was like oh wait that isn't him and
really what Scott what's what's [ __ ]
up is that he's aged but he's not an old
guy and in the face he doesn't look that
bad he's overweight he needs to lose
some weight look at that
Lukas the long Stallone is like
Methuselah as old as that guy is he's 70
gotta be 74 yeah if I still own looks
great you know man
course Stallone isn't natural he's
enhanced but he'd have a choice you know
time up but yeah look like that at that
age with the life yeah I mean you know
you're gonna get old we're just sitting
on somebody for getting old because
everyone does and and and you know
there's a lot of new [ __ ] out there too
[ __ ] in terms of pharmaceuticals and
technology's got a lot better you know
[ __ ] when it comes to certain things
that guys can take it looks like with
the right stuff and the right willpower
if you're in that gym working out and
you can maybe get like a facelift you
can keep the action [ __ ] thing going
for quite a bit for quite a long time
yeah look at the extol own in his late
60s early 70s he looked great you know
just like a bullet to the head a he had
to be his late 60s yeah he looks great
Rambo first blood his face looked a
little bit distorted we fixed it later
body-wise she looks great
um he you could say well I mean he
looked kind of old
yeah years old yeah he's old but if you
were to push the loan next to a the
random
[ __ ] 72-73 there's no
comparison
well ya know cookie doesn't look like
the average 72 year old man the [ __ ]
bill and it's all hunched over up under
his nose yeah and he's got a young wife
and kids and everything and he's an
intelligent dude and they say that when
Stallone walks into a [ __ ] bar with
all these big [ __ ] muscle men and gym
rats and [ __ ] like that he knows he
walks in like the alpha male and he's
not a big guy he's maybe five eight five
nine all right yeah just average but
date evidently like he everybody [ __ ]
love Stallone but he looks like a cool
dude yeah evidently he's just clean all
they do not seem like a goal did he see
now you wanna do a song okay I'm just
saying he comes across like a douche and
every single person that I've heard
talking about like even Howard Stern
look to bag on the dude yeah he's fun to
bag on just because he says something
and that I don't like the way I'm
dancing yes you really do show and it
believes you're really open for that
kind of chicanery where people are gonna
make fun of you knows you obviously
think a lot of yourself and I love
justify love glenn danzig music and [ __ ]
you know I mean I've never met the guy
but a lot of people bag on Danzig
because you know I mean he's very [ __ ]
right the same he doesn't have a sense
of humor didn't he see I'm very touchy
very similar to Steven Seagal in terms
of [ __ ] attitude you know I mean
[ __ ] those are hard can't relax yeah
those are very difficult people to be
around and it you know and I think
Seagal has the problem too of like
thinking that he's better than everyone
and think or at least projecting Matt to
other people where he thinks he knows
best he knows how to do everything and
he has to tell everybody had to do stuff
because nobody else knows how to do [ __ ]
but him because he's obviously like I'm
a CIA operative and a Navy SEAL and like
the Aikido master and I can do
everything in blah blah blah so he
thinks he's just like the best at
everything and he has to tell everyone
else it makes me wonder if he was trying
to compete with his peers of that day
back then because he had Frank Dux doing
that and he was getting success yet a
lot of people that were lying back then
well ya can't get away and you know he
talked his way into Hollywood yeah okay
and then told a bunch of stories name in
movies about him so it could be that he
felt he had to do the same thing and now
he's like so now he's stuck I can't talk
his way out of that no he can't just go
he's not really a dude yeah he didn't
have the he doesn't have the kind of
flexible personality we go oh no that's
so easy to do back then yeah we just we
were all [ __ ] yeah we were
bullshitting back then you know this
week on movies I don't have a problem
with some good [ __ ] but I was saying
because you want it yeah then just be
like yeah you got me yeah yeah yeah well
make a joke about it should have been
like back in those days we had to do
that we were making messes so business
man yeah
chill out which I feel funny about it
it's like he would see like a lot more
respect yeah and that's all if that's
his way out and and he's a little out of
style now he should have been talking
that way in the late night yeah it's
probably too late just a little bit too
late he's been stuck in trying to been
trying to maintain it for too long
everybody else is going oh yeah we used
to [ __ ] a lot back then yeah which
like I said that's fine yeah I don't
have a problem with bullshitting per se
as long as you're not like taking that
[ __ ] seriously and love punching people
over it because they're like laughing at
you like saying something ridiculous he
he did a lot of talk shows though you
know today the talk shows kind of people
asked him questions on talk shows you
know the man leg on [ __ ] [ __ ] what it
was but and and yeah he would try to he
was oh yeah yeah you can see walked off
some shows yes somebody asked him like
even ask him difficult questions he
really couldn't answer and he really was
[ __ ] yeah yeah and that's what I
mean it's like you couldn't get out of
it yeah if you can't like deal with that
kind of [ __ ] then people are gonna like
that game yeah in martial arts he's not
he's not a likeable partner right yeah
like I said you know Stallone is a
likeable guy like a lot of this action
stars if you see them like you see
interviews with them and stuff like that
they seem right like likeable dudes they
seem like regular dude there's a lot of
there's a big difference between Seagal
Stallone
Stallone started as an actor true he
never made claims of being a really a
pro boxer or to be really which is good
because she's mercenaries not what am i
you're right he was just like a game is
always an actor that was an actor and a
writer and that's all he ever claimed
today right so very different Segal got
into the [ __ ] movie gig by saying no
I'm an Aikido master cuz he was yeah and
that is true yes but then he has to
[ __ ] pile on top of that I'm also
worked for this I also [ __ ] he said
he did because he was a consultant for
the trainer's for certain CIA operatives
and his wife many times said no well
here's the weird thing
what is a CIA operative the CIA
operative isn't a guy in the CIA it's a
guy who works for an agent other words
like Sony who may be a criminal for the
CIA work is recruited to do a certain
job say maybe he talked to a criminal
that [ __ ] claimed to have been doing
something or a CIA agent that's many
like oh that's very what that means
that's exactly what he said and I
consulted for a CIA operative that's
very different from an agent yeah and
consultant was [ __ ] consulted me
where they had a bar drinking yeah and
[ __ ] they talked about titties
I mean wow that actually sounds that
sounds more like what they're talking
about
that sounds probable so and then he goes
oh and do this net and then there you go
yeah that's the same kind of [ __ ] that
likes you like inflate their resumes and
except akin to like a monstrous extreme
now Ducks it was even worse
Frank duck said he was CIA that he was
that's why yeah agent yeah and then he's
showing himself with all these NV G's
which is means night-vision goggles or a
nice vision glass yeah picture I think
everything I'm looking at and I'm gonna
minutes I got PVS too and that's a
[ __ ] they were like they were like
the kind of night vision we had in the
in the army that was already obsolete
and they forced us to carry it and then
when we
the field we didn't want to put it on
the [ __ ] rifle yeah because if half
the [ __ ] didn't work and the image was
not clear and I mean so that's the last
thing a [ __ ] CIA agent would need is
a damn night-vision scope that's not
what the CIA is about
yeah the CIA is just mostly about
recruiting people that work in companies
and trying to steal [ __ ] trying to
steal technology that a company's making
or lying and spinning things and telling
the newspaper people who you bribed what
to write to put a [ __ ] bad news
article in foreign it you know against
an enemy here's the it's more [ __ ]
stuff than that CIA is not he always
kind of they always kind of complained
CIA with special operatives you know in
Special Forces type guys what they're
talking about vietnam-era like max SOG
yeah you know which is special studies
and observation groups you know where
they're trying to figure out what the
what the what the Vietcong was doing and
the NVA was doing that was another era
they don't do that anymore
ya know well nothing cyber hacking it
you know one gave them the memo I guess
ya know it's that it's all that's
nowadays on CIA stuff is it's about
manipulating [ __ ] news news outfits
and [ __ ] hacking and bribe yeah it's
a lot more worrying now yeah it's a lot
more boring a lot more doing Joe kind of
a screen all day yeah they're not
dealing with you know cuz they're
talking about a time when there was
where the CIA was kind of like the
pinnacle of the intelligence agencies
now we got like 30 of those yeah yeah
and the Army has its own or your
military has its own with a flipper [ __ ]
that [ __ ] called
they don't matter but you know there's a
lot of redundancy in the system now
there's military versions of the CIA
yeah it sounds so much better if you say
well I have no see yeah that's what I
mean that's the thing it sounds good
until you think about it for five
seconds the NSA and then there's stuck
in all kinds of [ __ ] what I was gonna
say earlier about the [ __ ] that
we were watching the sniper special ops
the other night and we were I was making
a joke about like that being a stunt
double and then it actually was it's
done now I was watching I'd never walked
down the stairs so walk down the stairs
that's literally all the dude was like
at a normal pace so I thought that was
very funny so I was like I'm not gonna
sit through a whole like new or Steven
Seagal movie because like even that one
was like super boring but um I found
this guy this other guy on YouTube who
reviews me because I've seen some others
hips reviews to name mr. gg and he
watched a couple of the newer you know
Steven Seagal movies and apparently even
going back to one and I think it came
out in either 2006 or 2009 I can't
remember like I can't revert the name of
what was cuz all the names of his movies
are like the same but uh hard to kill
after kill hard to swallow kill yeah
kill ol dozer I don't find it so it's
like so they're all like that
so even going back to this movie from
2006 I think it was there was a shot and
he showed like a screenshot of it he's
like for real there's a shot of a dude
walking out like onto a balconies just
like walking across the room and across
the balcony and it is clearly not Steven
Seagal even though it's supposed to be
him and then he's like and then the
double turns toward the camera and you
could see it sucking face and you could
see that it's not Steven Seagal so
clearly they did not give a crap and
this is going but and this is like
[ __ ] 15 16 years ago he was using
doubles back so he was using doubles
back then he's gonna say well no we
didn't plan to have that shot and I was
no longer on you know on the scene so we
recreated it we needed somebody to go in
there and that seems like what he does
is that yeah that's what evil because he
always comes up with an excuse where if
somebody says something like hey all
that Aikido [ __ ] like they do like that
looks fake and everything he's like oh
well you know the people that I knocked
out is like well they have to fall down
otherwise like they would get hurt if
they kept standing there and he always
like has some excuse for like why it
looks super lame like when he's fighting
and stuff can we please talk about the
pants [ __ ] yeah it's time
this is a very famous story about Steven
Seagal but it's like I don't really know
how I mean it seems like most of the
[ __ ] that I was only posted people need
this story but I don't know how many of
our listeners know this story
so apparently what happened this was
either with I don't remember if it was
on a movie set or if it was just like on
some kind of thing so here is um what's
the dude's name GG labelled judo gene
LeBell yeah he's like an old school he's
one of the founders of like MMA or
something like that he was like one of
the ones that was renting he trained
Ronda Rousey did he not did a bunch of
stuff yeah so he later Jeff was stuntmen
didn't he yeah yeah and so yes so he's
like a big deal like in the [ __ ] yeah
he's evidently like the nicest guy in
the world yes so I've heard
yeah he's not a dick at all um unlike
some other people yeah yeah so and he's
a toughy he's only was tough even as an
old yeah he's like a old guy yeah he's
all guys so he apparently they're so
they're talking and Steven Seagal
apparently makes the claim that either
because if his I caterer is special like
[ __ ] magic powers or whatever he has
like a technique that means that he
can't be choked out yeah he could like
if you Seagal says that if you put him
in a headlock he tried chuck him out he
has a way to like tense up but he has a
way to like them so you can't [ __ ]
choke him out into unconsciousness that
he can keep his blood right going just
by cure so you make it claim like that
around somebody like gene LeBell he's
like yeah prove it come here yeah
now according to gene LeBell and some
other people that were there present
what ended up happening is that gene
LeBell puts Steven Seagal in a headlock
yeah
got a choke or some kind of chew and old
if it was a naked chokehold or something
like whatever they call it like in judo
because I think that's his that's gene
LeBell since judo is it not yeah so so
yeah so he puts him in in the chokehold
Steven Seagal then tries to then starts
struggling for breath then tries to
punch gene LeBell in the nuts yeah which
is kind of you know low blow do that and
then he passes out my sisters yeah
because she logo won't say not sir balls
or anything he just doesn't in the two
sisters in the system yeah that's what
he says so so yeah and which is kind of
cheating like I said thought so but he's
still doing the chokehold Steven Seagal
apparently passes out goes unconscious
and then shits his pants shits his
family he's a [ __ ] slid one slid out
that's the story well now yeah and
somebody else is like proof I heard
somebody else that said they were that
like gene LeBell says that too and he
said like well you know if somebody and
gene LeBell is so funny because he was
just kind of like he didn't wasn't like
laughing at Steven Seagal really but he
was just saying you know man
I I did that and it's like you know if
you ate a big meal beforehand it's like
so you know that again that kind of [ __ ]
that could happen you know what I mean
he wouldn't say [ __ ] cuz he but you know
what I mean it's like so he just said so
he wasn't [ __ ] he wasn't like laughing
at him necessarily it was just trying to
be nice about it but that made it even
funnier than he was trying to be nice
about it and now somebody else that was
supposedly there said that he's like so
yeah so he's like so Steven Seagal just
kind of goes unconscious and he's like
all of a sudden you just hear a price no
that's it and then yeah and that's what
they said they said he went and then
like you can't back is just like smelled
like [ __ ] really bad now obviously like
Steven Seagal denies yeah did this
happen he called you labelled a scumbag
liar all this other kind of stuff so I
don't like I wasn't there I don't know
if he really should his pants or not but
I don't know now another funny thing too
is that like I said when Steven Seagal
came out calling gene LeBell a scumbag
Ronda Rousey came back and she does not
like it cuz gene LeBell trained her and
she does not like people like [ __ ]
on gene so she just said you know why
don't you like have Steven Segal come
over here I'll make him crap his pants
again that's like I would [ __ ] a to
see that [ __ ] that would be [ __ ]
hilarious but yeah so I don't know this
just like that is probably the most
famous story about Steven Seagal
nowadays that he should this pants when
she will melt like choked about it's
like allegedly allegedly that's all this
alleges all legit it just seems like
okay so do you want to do more funny
stuff worries you want to pour you into
the dark [ __ ] or what well because like
I said I looked up during the break this
is why this is this is on every this
computer is on over here because I found
like some there were some articles on
cracked like the about there was one
that was called Steven Seagal man miss
lunatic also on that's called seven
superpowers that Steven Seagal thinks he
has and what about I read Steven
Seagal's insane novels so you don't have
to ok yes that was Sean baby but yeah so
I'm laughing at this one I think this
was a Louis Prada who were at this one
made myth lunatic there was like some
really funny [ __ ] [ __ ] in here like
the first paragraph is the sense if
Steven Seagal was good at fighting as he
is it being physically incapable of
backing up even 1% of his claims we
would all be wearing the illustrious
Lord Siegel's mandatory plus size which
reminds me that when he went to the
Oscars this must've been a long time ago
cuz why would he be invited years
nowadays but apparently well I mean
because you know he's a large man so he
had to have the tuxedo like made and he
wanted to make it super baggy so he
could like go to the Oscars packing
because apparently he's like super
paranoid and things people are after him
however it should be noted that
allegedly everything in this is
allegedly okay allegedly allegedly he
owed a bunch of money to the mob for
some [ __ ] it like he borrowed money from
the Mafia like for many many geared of
hookers ever doing something I don't
know why and apparently like they were
they kind of wanted to kill him because
he hadn't paid them off and he was like
shaking in his boots and he actually
gave them like seven or fifty thousand
dollars or five hundred thousand he had
he gave them like some big amount
because apparently he owed them some
money so there was mafia involvement
allegedly there was also the thing where
where he got he got in trouble with the
SEC because I don't really understand
how this works but apparently he was
plugging some like [ __ ] Bitcoin site
but they gave him a bunch of money to
plug it and he didn't disclose that and
apparently you have to do that you're
right um that if you're a celebrity and
you're endorsing like a particular
product or a security or something like
that you have to tell them that you have
to tell people that they gave you money
to do that and he didn't do that so he
got fined like a whole bunch of money
for doing that so he's been in trouble
with the law like a few times and stuff
and I think like that whole mafia case I
think he actually did testify at a trial
because I read an excerpt from a book
that the judge in that trial right he
wasn't like the you know the one that
was in trouble necessarily but it was
like one of the mobsters like trials
like you had to like get to be a witness
he had to be a witness at it yeah so
some of the other funny [ __ ] that was on
here was like they call him the man with
the fighting style of a convulsing
marionette trying to brush cracker
crumbs off the face of a second
convulsing Mary what they see just like
his fighting style okay talking about
you know and then Oh at first glance I
couldn't tell you Segal's ethnicity but
he looks like the kind of guy who's been
banned from a local Denny's he claims to
be Italian when the only Italian in
amour the flecks of salami clinging to
his goatee he also has a history of
telling people he's Asian
I bet whenever he wants to give friends
a sampling of his traditional culture he
takes in a Panda Express
since he's basically a living version of
Panda Express his disdain for the food
they serve so he never killed someone
I'm sure he'd flee to a Benihana
thinking it gave him the same immunities
and Japanese epithet
so he he actually claimed being Asian
yeah he has okay yeah he's claimed being
all kind of different races because I've
heard him talk some in the past and what
and he was doing like like a Chinese or
Japanese that's right I don't even know
what his real voice he probably doesn't
even know at this point my phone I've
heard him talk like a black person I've
heard you talk like a Brooklynite I've
heard him talk like a Creole sign kind
of you know animates it it's just like I
don't know like man
that's what I need that's why I called
the show the enduring enigma because
he's just wondered he fascinated like I
I can't I kind of can't stand him but
like he's also really interesting
because he's just the kind of people
that the kind of people that are this
like out there and they don't realize
tend to be crazy like pathological liars
yeah and it's like in it and it freaks
me out like that he's really that
clueless about maybe he just thinks it
maybe he's not really thinking much
about it he goes on a show maybe no this
kind of changes his persona for that one
show and maybe he's not thinking about
how other people are gonna forgive and
there's mercy then there's really kind
of like no continuity into what he's
doing and it's just because he tried
maybe whatever situation he you put him
in he plays to that audience to that
room not realizing that it's recorded
not thinking it through that's recorded
it would but also not realizing that
it's really obvious that he's doing that
in every way just thinks it's super win
and he thinks he's fooling people yeah
it's like that's why you need to be
anything he made fool a lot of people
mean he does have fans I once I once
[ __ ] said some sideways [ __ ] about
him on a video on YouTube and had I had
like five guys jump on me
yeah and it was about I said a city were
probably 12 and it was about him talking
like he was Japanese or that he
pretended to be Asian and they swore up
and down that that wasn't true and when
you said he claimed to be age and I was
like I was right yeah he says let's
remember him talking like that I didn't
know the exs trash they imagine I don't
remember that I didn't I didn't realize
he had claims he goes around wearing the
[ __ ] it's okay he's wearing oriental
clothing and [ __ ] sometimes these are
like kimonos yeah remember he used to
have a little ponytail he deficits then
does he still have it no I guess not
no wait now in the movie try to have a
little Chinese ponytail in the movie we
saw that was from 2006 City I'm pretty
sure I said he had like a where do rag
type of thing going
he was supposed to be dressed like an
army guy what's so funny is he's like 60
something but he's kind of showing
himself in on active duty and they were
really did write it said special ops but
everybody in there would be a little too
old to be a specialist everybody had a
mullet and gravy elevation yes I don't
think that would be allowed for me for
certain circumstances but not nothing
under cover but they were not yeah there
were certain times there were certain
times in Afghanistan where they wanted
to look like a local but I think they
might have kind of dropped that because
it's obvious that they weren't locals
that's what I'm saying it's like you're
not I don't know exactly what they were
doing you know during the time that I
was in they wore beards but it was
mostly so you couldn't recognize him and
that was that was in that [ __ ] and I
think that was only in the context of
certain missions yeah I don't know what
they were like you know [ __ ] normally
I just saw photographs of them you know
what I mean like in Gulf War one yeah
run around the damn dune buggies and
ships they had and they had beards but I
don't know if they were wearing those
beards when they were [ __ ] back at
whatever the fort they were at that's
not where they have been out of their
house I don't know if they had beards or
not if they grew the beards where they
were in the field she seemed very
strange like even seeing this seeing
this movie I was just like I don't
really know if if this was supposed to
be a realistic operation like if that
would be allowed if that's what if
that's what they would look like SF and
del plus the uniforms are not right you
said yeah yeah they weren't right and
Delta is a part of SF Delta was always
it was kind of sketchy you know me I
never did they they're supposed to
they're not even supposed to exist so
when they're doing [ __ ] you know I mean
they're not wearing uniforms they're not
really then they would just kind of
vanish and go back they were did a lot
of [ __ ] in the island of Grenada and
breaking people out of prison and
they're good at that kind of stuff you
know get somebody out of prison from
another country that's a weird [ __ ] when
you think about it you know that they
were doing that kind of stuff it's like
that [ __ ] yeah and here's here's a weird
thing well
getting somebody out of prison who's
valuable to them and yeah there's also
kind of a war going on at the time they
might like they were attacking the
island at the time but here's the deal
is like some of the [ __ ] they would do
kind of technically be illegal you know
because they're doing an operation
that's kind of like war but no war has
been declared which if they were caught
they'd be [ __ ] yeah imagine he
probably could get him out but maybe not
it's hard to say they always did kind of
sketchy [ __ ]
but Seagal doesn't know anything about
that and that movie that they made
that's not that's not it that's not the
real thing
well even even me who doesn't know like
a great deal about that [ __ ] I was just
kind of like this just looks like a
bunch of cosplayers yeah it's exactly
and not particularly guess what it was
and you know enrolled to be in theater
doing what they were doing I mean you
saw Seagal [ __ ] leaned down and
grabbed that wounded dude turned dragged
him and you could obviously see he went
yeah I mean just think if you were in a
unit of guys and you got you were out in
the open and somebody somebody with
machine gun opened up on you at [ __ ]
hard yards everybody started to scatter
and run right with Seagal be able to
[ __ ] make it out of that [ __ ] Niles
out know he'd be [ __ ] calm down
you couldn't depend on him in whatever
yes Oh in one of the in the same in the
same article where Sean baby said that
he ran like a penguin who's kidding
yeah he also said nowadays you could out
distance him in an elevator
which you know it's terrible but it's
like like I said the reason people pick
on him is just because he's so [ __ ]
because he's still going around like
acting like this big tough badass when
that's obviously not what he is and he
doesn't like have a sense of humor about
it yeah also this is also alleged but
now that were going back to the mob
stuff allegedly
he asked a hitman he paid a hitman
$50,000 for $500,000 to have somebody
whacked maybe two times one of them was
a journalist that that picked on him and
said some [ __ ] about it but he didn't
like which that's mature and the other
one
I can't remember who the other one was
um he he has a real problem with like
what does he care what a journalist says
with well that's what I mean he has a
real problem with like you know right I
think Vanity Fair like did kind of a
like a article about him like several
years ago and he got really pissed off
about that it might have been that guy
that he that he wanted killed but um
it's just he also has a real problem
with with women journalists and with
women that interview him because he says
that's like the main problem and he
calls him like a bunch of [ __ ] [ __ ]
I think that's a direct quote Seth yeah
but yes so he's not real and you can
tell this from like his [ __ ] novel
which I don't know how much of it he
wrote it's like he it's telling about
the novel it's him it's like this crazy
thing where he's it's fiction but it's
supposedly based on real and it's just
this crazy like conspiracy theory
everything it's called the shadow wolves
and like the deep state and also that
kind of crap and then like he is writing
himself as the main character it's not
the main character isn't Steven Seagal
he is a different name it's like John
Mann tangoed or something like that and
he's like a Native American of course
and he's like a magical Native American
whose name's Rain Bird yeah it's a bite
is what's under bird it might as well be
and he can just like do everything and
like he has like all these magical
Native American powers where he just
like has [ __ ] and they're like try
and there's like all these [ __ ] it's
what's it even about I don't even know
it's like the writing is like really bad
and it's just kind of like he didn't
write it write it like he had this other
guy named Tom Morris he's like who's
like this 80 year old weirdo and um he
like they wrote it together but it's
just kind of like I don't it was
something to do it's like [ __ ]
Islamic terrorists coming over the
Mexican border working with the drug
cartel some [ __ ] like that's a whole
that's and yeah and it was it was like
that sounds like he's trying to make a
Tom Clancy novel with him in it kind of
yeah but it's like different yeah and
like I said that the main character is
clearly supposed to be him and it's like
again it's just kind of like the
characters in his movies where he knows
how to do everything he has like [ __ ]
magical psychic powers like he has all
these special like he even says this
[ __ ] like on his [ __ ] reality
like he'll say [ __ ] like you know well
I've been doing martial arts for so many
decades so I I know like the way you
thinkin yeah he says that he knows like
what so II think so he drives through
neighborhoods he's like he can just tell
when someone's gonna do crime right
because it's like the way they're
standing or the way they turn their head
or something like that like he thinks
that he knows what that how people are
gonna like commit a crime and he just
knows for some reason even though
apparently I haven't seen like a lot of
the shows I've just seen clips from it
I'm not gonna sit through three seasons
that [ __ ] yeah but um it just seems like
most I think I'm interested I mean the
real cops I'm sure you could probably
see it on YouTube would imagine I just I
think it was on A&E like I said for the
first two seasons maybe it got suspended
like cuz of all the [ __ ] um when you
know when he was in all that legal
trouble right but then it came back for
a third one and then like I said there
was another show - called true justice
that I think that might have premiered
on some channel in Spain and then like
it showed in Europe and then I think it
showed over here maybe like on some one
of the weird cable channels and now
they're like putting them out like they
they did like some old [ __ ] like they
used to do with those crappy shows in
the 70s we're like they would take like
two episodes and like mash them together
and like make a movie quote unquote out
of it like these like they did with like
[ __ ] Gemini man and all that yeah I
think they're doing that so I haven't
seen those Gemini man what's that that
was like it was they it was this
horrible 70s show that like about this
guy that could make himself invisible
they did like they did own MST but now
you got me interested man because it's
like well it really does seem like like
I said not only is he like really super
condescending and he's just like telling
people there's this what like one great
[ __ ] clip where he's you know the cop
the actual cop is like driving the
patrol car and Steve's in like the
passenger seat or whatever and he's like
a total like backseat well I guess like
a front seat driver he's just kind of
like just to the right to the right and
the cop totally says Steve let me drive
so it's like I thought I wonder if like
some of these cops are like Jesus Christ
it's like we're trying to do do our
[ __ ] job and like here's this douche
like [ __ ] thinking he knows
everything
you want to see this [ __ ] now that is it
entertaining wondered that is the
funniest funny you should ever came well
just because like I said he's I mean
this is like a small this is a like
[ __ ] you know downtown Chicago or
anything it's not like it says tiny
little parish in Louisiana it's like
really there's like you know they break
up a couple fights in a parking lot it's
like it's nothing like serial distillers
this Segal give words of wisdom and [ __ ]
and I think he does yeah that's what I
mean so like he'll like turn toward the
exit you know like I said he thinks he
knows everything I gotta see this and
that he that his martial arts training
has given him magical powers and he has
like that [ __ ] my insight into some of
that [ __ ] that none of us and mortals
have absolutely some that [ __ ] might
[ __ ] bring back certain nostalgia
within me where you probably love where
it takes you back to the 80s of playing
like [ __ ] we're gonna have to watch
this Street Fighter games
I don't want rowdy games you know I mean
[ __ ] ninja Jam and [ __ ] and I'm
listening to this dude tell me how
[ __ ] how his Chi can detect [ __ ]
crime I'd like to see that I'm kind of
like obviously like I said I've seen
clips I mean think that worries me
alright only thing that worries me is
that I try to avoid boredom yeah you
know talk about yeah and a lot of the
later Segal stuff is just boring it's
not that one yeah that sniper movie that
was like we could even City yeah yeah I
had it fast-forward through most of it
and wherever he was and there was some
[ __ ] that I watched it was just it's
just boring yeah that's the problem with
it it wasn't terrible it just was boring
I mean it was comedy was come and I just
there wasn't money thing there and it's
like you can obviously tell that the
movies were made for a Steven Seagal fan
yeah somebody who's in the Steven Seagal
universe you wouldn't have to be this
yummy way I don't know other than that
it was just kind of like a competently
made short
stretched out - what about an hour and
15 20 minutes and it was almost kind of
like a fan-made is what it felt like
they didn't really fight it and I
honestly I've seen bad
fan-made yeah that word but it just
seemed like not much was going on how
much is going on mostly welcome it just
seemed like mostly just sitting around
and every now and then sniping somebody
and you can't really compare that to
what his original material that made him
famous what that was like well some of
those were actually dia action movie
we're at yeah this first five or six
movies actually were fun they were very
entertaining I would say the best one
would be under siege and I think
everyone agrees that under siege is the
best one yes I don't like much argument
on that how do i dar die hard but it's
on a battleship yeah and not this not
the same level of artistic [ __ ]
content not the same acting content but
you know a common competent and it was
fun to watch
yeah under siege to was fun to watch
you've no but evidently that bombed but
I liked watching it it was funny
it was fun very similar to under siege
one hard to kill was good he comes up
out of a coma and [ __ ] reeks revenge
and [ __ ] yeah the other one what was the
one with he you know he was the cop at
the beret I thought that was cheesy was
kind of like a fake kind of like a fake
Lethal Weapon not quite as good I forgot
that one was called Alfred justice I
think was going out for justice it had a
couple good scenes in it just not really
might think but really when that's what
his career was built on was really yeah
that was kind of it
those were decent movies they were
entertaining evidently the beginning of
the bad movies where the was the ones
where he is becoming [ __ ] he's up on
an in a damn oil rig and he's on deadly
ground on deadly ground since
directorial David and that was the start
of that that was evident but I always
need that one though that was when he
had completely vanished up his own
bottle yeah and he was kind of like you
know I'm all for environmentalism fun
but it's like won the stupid thing he
don't give a [ __ ] about you doesn't give
a [ __ ] about yeah yeah sure right he's
like in on deadly ground he's all like
it has this [ __ ] four or five minute
speech about how
we have to like save the earth everyone
want to see the ocean yes that's good
but then in the movie he basically he
blows up an oil rig like in the ocean
right and I'm like you know looted more
the ocean than they would have done yeah
if [ __ ] you know what I mean it's like
it just seems like every everything
about him just seems really hypocritical
and he doesn't seem to realize it I
gotta see this but yeah that totally
went downhill once he went into like
this really weird environment and like I
said it's like he's all kind of like Oh
animal rights and everything and then he
just like drives a tank through this
guy's house kills a puppy and then he
kills all these chickens allegedly yeah
you know what I mean he doesn't give a
[ __ ] about that it's like he just gives
a [ __ ] about like pretending that he's
this big wise Asian man in China yeah
he's trying to make the Dalai Lama Opare
oh that was an exam that was another
story I can't remember who told this one
cuz I I watched like this one was clips
it was like Howard Stern that was Rob
Schneider there was like all these
different people and they were talking
about like working with him and like all
the stupid [ __ ] that he did and one of
them said that he had just been to visit
with the Dalai Lama because apparently
you can be a to God if you yeah you give
enough money to the charities or
something you can have like an audience
with him or whatever so he goes there
and apparently the Dalai Lama made him
yeah like a deity made him a deity and
then walking around feeling special
yeah and he's actually like in complete
and total seriousness then it's like yet
in the Dalai Lama and his wisdom has
made me like a D or whatever the word is
but Rob Schneider money basically
amazing a [ __ ] father I don't even
remember what the [ __ ] word is it was
like his [ __ ] it I thought it started
with a T it's like a P a short word but
yeah he made him like some demigod like
yeah like like a reincarnated like soul
or something like that and it's like and
the funny thing was he said so he's
talking all this [ __ ] about oh oh now I
feel like I really have to do something
because he made me like a deity and yeah
in his wisdom above and then like
they're like and then his like [ __ ]
publicist or whatever comes in and says
hey your ex-wife called and you know she
can't pick up the kids or whatever you
tell that [ __ ] [ __ ] that there's like
like I believe that I've laid that that
sounds about right because here's the
thing yo Steven Seagal is really not
this is there are so many so many
allegations so I already mentioned the
thing where there's clearly a photo of
him like grams a 16 year olds titty and
and according to her he told he told her
that he was trying to get up in that
booty I have girlfriends your age and
she's like you had agree I don't believe
that though please get me away from he
was just trying to talk his way into it
guys Dean gross but yeah but yeah so
there are numerous numerous stories bro
check the laws in that local state oh
that's age of consent
yeah so there are many allegations like
I said and in case you didn't in case
you had any Mike of respect left for
this dude
so among the people that have that have
come out like accusing him of various
things Lisa Guerrero who was a
correspondent for Inside Edition for a
while she was also went to an audition
for a fire down below one of Steven
Seagal movies what are the shitty ones
this was in 1996 she says that she was
going there to try out for a role and
when she gets there like she would be
casting age there was no one there him
in a damn casting couch yeah and so all
this other kind of stuff like I said
Jenny McCarthy was also trying out for
under siege too and he told her like hey
get naked like she yes she thought she
goes and knocks to like audition
thinking there would be other people
there which is normally you got this
yeah and she was like yeah no thank you
and she left
Rachel Grant who was in the Bond movie
Die Another Day um she said the same
thing she was going to audition for out
for a kill which came out in 2003 and he
apparently pushed her onto the bed and
pulled his pants down Dan um one of them
and actually one woman said that he
actually raped her when she was 18 years
old so yeah and allegedly [ __ ] alleged
allegedly allegedly allegedly like a lot
of the stuff you
as he said she said although he said
also that he was in the CIA he's God and
all this other stuff so I don't think
I'm gonna believe this [ __ ] on anything
you know what I'm saying and honestly
the way he comes across he comes across
like such a skeevy douche and like a lot
of this like I've read like um excerpts
of his of his novel I'm just gonna I'm
making bunny rabbit ears if you're
listening to the audio version because I
don't really want to give it that
distinction now I don't know how much of
of Steven Seagal is in the novel or how
much of the ghostwriters in the novel
but like the female characters in this
novel they all love him yeah and and are
clearly not like any human woman like is
ever existed on the face of the earth
ever and so him being like a creepy
sexual molester is just not a shock
tomato allegedly it's not a shock tomato
because he absolutely seems like that
kind of person and so like well he does
it's like he he just comes across like
that you know I'm not saying that he did
do those things but I'm just saying
there's a really lot of claims against
him and he seems like somebody that
would do that type of thing to me like
he seems that kind of personality so
yeah um there was also Jaime Pressly who
also said that he did that whole like oh
I'm a shiatsu master and that grabs the
boobs yeah looking for lumps yeah that's
a lot I'm like really you can think
really you can think of better than that
oh my god I would I would knock his fat
ass down so fast if he did that I don't
think it was fat during that time I
think he was younger back then god damn
it that's it that's some [ __ ] up [ __ ]
I think there was a holiday gave him
some [ __ ] bad habits oh I bet you he
was seeing other dudes getting with all
kinds of [ __ ] so he's like well I can I
can do it too I'm Steven so I'm just
gonna do whatever I can do to him
Stevie's go yeah don't do that you guys
I mean I shouldn't have but yeah and
it's like well to me it's not funny but
you know to me so but yes so there and
there was also the very famous
allegation that this one woman he
actually brought a million dollar
lawsuit
against em now she was um she was hired
on as an executive assistant and when
she started working for him she
discovered
according to her that he was keeping two
underage girls in his house that
apparently were they had to like do
whatever he said they had to be on call
yes 24/7 so for whatever as fact
whenever he needed his nob slobbered on
yeah
they had their underage I'm pretty sure
they were underage well that's what she
was alleging that they were alleged and
that um apparently I don't know that's
why the whole thing was sex late because
apparently she was saying that they
couldn't leave like I don't know if he
had taken their passports or whatever
the [ __ ] he had done but uh you know
allegedly allegedly but um yes so she
was trying too soon for that and uh the
charges were dropped
later on but she dropped the charge
without explaining anything so I don't
know if he threatened her I don't know
okay for a big payoff I don't know what
the deal was there but there definitely
I mean there comes a point where cuz the
shitty thing about looking like [ __ ]
bill cosby right and it's like people
have been talking about like the
allegations against Bill Cosby for like
forever but nobody would really listen
but then it seemed like once it gets to
a critical mass and it's like how many
[ __ ] people have to come forward and
say yes this dude did these horrible
things before people will listen but how
many women was a thirty forty it was
like a lot whatever they people have
been like - he he got convicted he did
yeah how much time did he get I don't I
don't remember he's locked up he's
locked up yet okay so I feel like the
same thing you know there can only be
there's a pattern of behavior and he
really does seem to come across like
that like I said his is one of his
ex-wives Kelly LeBrock is I don't think
she came out and said directly that he
had physically abused her but she
implied that he had you know what I mean
like her interviews yet does she implied
that he had also you know so I
definitely feel like there is probably
some [ __ ] there because he just
definitely seems like he comes across
like that he because he's very much like
I'm I'm a sex symbol I'm the best at
everything I always been like you know
calling like and specifically saying
things like and he's been quoted as
saying like you know women reporters or
women that ask him questions [ __ ]
[ __ ] like saying [ __ ] like that so you
do that kind of [ __ ] you know it it
really doesn't endear me toward you and
like I said I've I've read like the [ __ ]
in his book like about all the female
characters book I'm like yeah that
sounds like a rapist [ __ ] it does like
allegedly it sounds like somebody that
doesn't see women as people well this is
a legend that's what I said okay is that
everything and this is allegedly but
there have been so many I think he's
just kind of a clueless [ __ ] who
thinks his head got pretty big and he
thought he could do whatever he wanted
yeah but that's not good no no it's not
good he also oh another thing that he
claims to and this is like coming down a
little bit from the other [ __ ] but it's
like he also claims that he's the
world's foremost expert on Asian swords
and that and that auction houses come to
him to authenticate swords and stuff
like that
don't tell me it's not true don't tell
me I'm pretty sure that's not true I
mean like I said all the stuff that he
says I don't even know if people even
bother because they think he's probably
like so irrelevant now because it's just
like he's just like straight-to-dvd King
or whatever make him like [ __ ]
however many zillion movies he's made
since the early Tia's that's why it's
not quality as quantity he's gonna make
a bunch of I bet he's got his own little
fan club so he put he must because he
still keeps putting them out I'm out so
he must be making money now I have it I
think he's got a [ __ ] big spread that
he lives in and he's remarried huh yeah
he might be on his fourth wife at this
point and she has seven kids by four
different when right and they're all
grown so he's not paying most of them
are grown yeah yeah and I think he I
think he lives in Russian Avenue I
believe he did he has I don't know if he
renounced his US citizenship but he has
Russian citizenship and Serbian alright
citizenship okay although he apparently
he's not allowed in some countries like
the Ukraine and
stuff like that because of his support
for the invasion of Crimea which you
know some people were kind of like upset
about so he's banned from a couple of
countries for being like not influenced
or whatever so uh so there's some issues
there but it's just I don't know I don't
know what his deal is
I don't really know it's he amuses me in
a sense because I see his movies like
[ __ ] case cinema he's done like some of
his newer ones didn't you do that one
with like put some they're [ __ ]
vampires in it am I remembering it wrong
yeah no he did a vampire movie I thought
it was vampire yes
cinsay was walking around with a damn
sword and [ __ ] remember that and
everybody it was just basically walking
the idea was like very very slowly as
yes no it is like I said some of these
movies that he comes up with the the
premises sound like they could be good
but whoever's writing them they're not
they're just boring and I saw like um I
saw this mr. Gigi on YouTube and he
reviewed a couple of his newer ones and
he was like pointing it out because I
guess he's kind of like you know a
filmmaker and stuff like that so he was
pointing out like he's like among the
other things of this just being boring
and Steven Seagal being hardly in it and
you can't understand what he's saying
and like the plot being nonsensical and
everything like that he's like also the
editing is like really really bad really
bad if he'd had some talent behind him
writing scripts and - and editing
something with some imagination some of
that [ __ ] could have been pretty good
yeah like so the ideas were not bad like
behind the movies it could have been
like just a fun but that's the think
they're not fun but right and you see at
Segal's age and in the condition that
he's in he really should be making fun
movies not once not once where he's
pleased this area be like a badass right
because no one's gonna buy that it could
be like a funny badass yeah it's why
don't you do some [ __ ] like say you know
like um you know some of those old like
kung fu movies Sammo hung or something
like
it was like kind of chunky but he could
still do that kind of [ __ ] right I don't
think Steven Seagal can do anything cuz
he can't like walk down [ __ ] stairs
anymore he can walk down stairs he he
just doesn't wanna just didn't want to
be seen walking down those stairs
because he didn't really like it I guess
he thinks he's too heavy but there's an
easy solution for them a stoppie yeah
he's not you know a [ __ ] he doesn't
look like a little old man and any
bright you know I mean he could he could
make a movie lose some weight you really
wouldn't have to lose all that much
maybe forty pounds that make a big
difference on him probably it probably
what like I don't have any idea how much
you dig
he's yes so maybe 40 pounds wouldn't put
a dent in him but yeah I mean when you
talk about proportions he you don't have
to lose maybe one third of its size cuz
like looking at it from the side it's
kind of hard to tell because the movie
that decipher movie that we watched it's
like one it's weird because he was
wearing like the what the [ __ ] was that
was a bullet professor like it was it
ammo ammo belt he was wearing a vest and
that made him look like even more giant
yeah legit the vest was like an LC II
but was the best to have a [ __ ] you
know ammo pouches in it that's what I
was thinking but that made him look like
a lot bigger my body armor though yeah
but the thing about it is that for most
of the movie and and from what I
understand from like watching reviews of
like other of his other recent movies
it's like they pretty much will not show
like a full length of him like a full
length shot of him it'll just be like
close-ups of his face or he'll just
always be sitting down they don't ever
want to show them like walking around or
like walking down steps or anything like
that so they always kind of like keep
stuff above even though like everybody
knows what he looks like and it's like I
don't know like if he's not worried
about it then just produce the movies
and don't be idiot don't be in okay if
you don't like how you look but can
either lose the weight or don't be in
the damn movie or or go with it or run
yeah just roll with it just like go with
it and [ __ ] make yourself make it on
yeah make like a fun movie yet but he
doesn't really seem like basically
capable of doing that because he can't
like he makes fun of him
he's trying to maintain a certain image
and it's unrealistic government and that
image is that away like a long time ago
that that that image doesn't work that a
long time ago that's gone it's gone now
and nobody from that era has that same
image that they used to have they've all
changed yeah and like I said everybody
gets old there's no shame in that no
one's picking on him for being old yeah
they're picking on him because he's kind
of trying to be the same the way that
he's trying to put himself across is
obviously not the way he is and it's
like I don't know why he doesn't just
accept the way he is now if that's what
he wants to look like yeah and just roll
with that yeah you want to be in movies
like that just make a joke out of it or
me he's not that fat it's just he's just
he's not that fat yeah it's just that
he's not as skinny as he wants to be
different and and he and the way that he
is not obese yeah he's just he's just
chunky yeah but it's just like I said
he's he click roll away he could roll
with that yeah and it's like I don't
know why he doesn't it's like I don't
know why cuz look the whole like [ __ ]
Expendables thing and another thing by
the way is that he was actually asked to
be in that but he wouldn't be in it
because he didn't like one of the
producers of the movie or one of the
directors of the movie like he hated him
for some reason he show he wouldn't be a
day should've jumped at expense well
yeah and that's what everybody said it's
like because you know they got all the
big action stars in it yeah but the cool
thing about the Expendables is that you
know it's all these like aging action
stars and stuff they came back and they
did this movie because they could like
you know the movies not laughing at them
but it does it does like any comedy
though it is 70 semi comedy and it is
like acknowledging that they're all old
now yeah and and they're not trying to
be like oh I'm 20 years old and like
going around they're not trying to do
that they're acknowledging it and like
kind of making a joke but also make it a
good action movie and it's like he
doesn't really seem capable of going
that route and that's a shame you're
right
because if he could do that he might
actually have a career instead of just
going right to the D model he might be
able to regain relevance and turning up
the animal the other thing is those he's
never gonna relinquish control over what
he's makin to somebody else yeah he
definitely does oh [ __ ] he definitely
does seem like this weird like
dictatorial type of you know this is my
little fiefdom and they thrust them
they'll make fun of me yeah and so I do
feel like so like I said it's that
that's just to me a mark of a very very
insecure person that he's just kind of
like oh and we've got a lot of dirt
about him out there well yeah well he's
done a lot of shitty stuff it's like you
shouldn't have done all that [ __ ] yeah
if you're that worried about like don't
don't allegedly beat up your wives don't
allegedly sexually assault people don't
allegedly take money from the mob and
then get afraid they're gonna kill you
don't allegedly take money from [ __ ]
was too late well actually that's not
only late now that's not allegedly
because he actually did get too late
yeah that's what I mean yes probably too
late to save it it's like you if he
could have done that like in the early
2000s or them even the mid-2000s if he'd
have come out and been like I was a
douche and blah blah blah it's like I
think people would have like I think
come back in a brace I think he could
come clean maybe he'd have to have maybe
he would have to be able to eat have to
come to the light he'd have to be able
to laugh laugh at himself yeah and I
just like it's just I just don't know if
he's capable of doing it have to have to
like take kind of like oh can we talk
for a second before before we wrap the
show how long's to show yeah because
it's probably like half hours like um
one other thing I do want to mention was
his energy drinks
oh yeah the energy drink come hurt the
commercial was fantastic I thought okay
that commercial has a commercial I
thought it was a parody no he was
serious but it's awesome it's awesome I
thought it was somebody making fun of
Steven Seagal is commercial for the
powerhead for the drink commercial is is
it so guys [ __ ] a hot bikini chick in a
pool pouring the energy drink into the
pool and she's counting them down like
she's poured [ __ ] a thousands of
these [ __ ] drinks to fill the pool
and then it [ __ ] cuts over and and
there's a younger younger
sigalas he he looks pretty young then
but there might have been mm uh yeah
well was it late 90s or
I can't even he's sitting there [ __ ] it
so I got five I'm gonna come in there
and I'm gonna swimming in one and I'm
gonna get you I'm gonna get you that and
the name of the dev the name of the damn
drink is called Asian experience and
it's a it's an Asian girl he's gonna
have an Asian experience at any [ __ ]
moment it looked like something out of
like a porn film okay it was hilarious
can you imagine the logistics of
actually filling a swimming pool up with
energy drink and then like having sex in
that pool yeah within you just be all
sticky and like it and you'd smell like
sleeves are y'all an asian chick having
sex in the [ __ ] of in a pool filled with
Asian experience but it was an energy
drink it's [ __ ] awesome concept man
there were two there were two other
flavours one of them there both were
both the other flavors were not as funny
they were just all cherry charged and
root beer rush yeah but yeah we were
watching cinemassacre the other day and
that the guy that's on there that I had
a can that has your wall of Segal he
bought some cans for back back in the
day and they he still had them and they
were sealed and everything and he
actually like drank them on the show
said they were good yeah he said well
they said they weren't bad like for
energy drinks I'm sure old though - yeah
they were like 15 years right 2005 that
came it's and I think they didn't really
last very long but seriously if I wonder
if that commercials on youtube somewhere
of like the woman like porn cuz i sear I
for real thought that was I was like
that is not the real commercial I would
love to get one get one you know when
they were fresh and see what they tasted
like they probably taste like all the
other one for you practised by the same
I mean each arts yeah they all just
tastes like sweet tartan but energy I
like it he gets a sense it okay got
energy drinks I'm drinking that all
these energy energy drink with [ __ ]
that's right you got me what the hell is
it called thunder thighs it's gonna be
great okay green oak man he's like I've
ran out of drink like a long time cause
I didn't even get another one
more in a minute yeah we can get it down
all right so yeah we're doing this on
Friday night actually so uh all right so
that'll be the Terminator I know right
you didn't get hot in that jacket it's a
little warm but it's not I'm not hot
that's wet nervous it's actually not if
this office is always like really cold
for some reason I'm not really sure why
but I always like usually wear a sweater
in here some was like the reason my ass
off all right so hopefully you guys have
enjoyed this rambling discussion about
this the great legendary Steven Seagal
yeah don't beat us up don't sit on us
actually not worried about like a Steven
Seagal that's probably the more boring
don't eat me you might I'm teasing get a
sense of humor yeah all right anyway
hopefully you guys enjoyed episode 190
remember if you liked the show like
share subscribe on all your social media
if you'd like to financially support the
show during these rough times I know
it's kind of hard out there for
everybody but you know if you want to
we're doing it you can you know during
the apocalypse at the end of the world
whatever we have a patreon page
patreon.com/lenguin
- give a one-time donation anything
would be much appreciated
and we will see you next time bye I'll
be back
[Laughter]
[Music]
you
[Music]